Der FCM hat die rote Laterne zurück, Schalke thront wieder an der Spitze. Und sonst ist eigentlich pures Chaos angesagt. Wir wollen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer nach dem 25. Spieltag sprechen. Und das machen wir mit Kevin Bublitz vom Baader Cast und Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast. Und jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lageralp fliegt vorbei, der Ball ist im Tor!
Und Augsburg ist oben!
Russis zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Markner, Martin Markner.
Und das Anzündung. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, wir kommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Und keine Angst, ich habe Marc nicht rausgeschmissen oder sonst irgendwas. Irgendwie. Aber der war leider krank und deshalb konnte die letzte Folge eben auch nicht regulär erscheinen. Wir mussten die komplett ausfallen lassen. Das hatte einfach ein bisschen was bei uns in der Organisation zu tun und mit Terminen, die man leider einfach mal nicht gerade so eben verschieben konnte. Deshalb sorry dafür, dass es dafür eben auch keinen Ersatz gab. Aber wir sind jetzt wieder da und ich darf an meiner Seite ein absolutes Traumduo begrüßen. Es ist das, man könnte sagen Traumduo des All-Star-Teams. Zum einen ist Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast mal wieder mit dabei. Hallo, Thomas. Du bist noch stumm.
Hallo, Eva und hallo, Kevin. Ja, genau, es ist spät.
Das ist okay. Ich würde sagen, das kriegen wir alles hin und dann natürlich auch herzlich willkommen zurück an Kevin Bublitz zum zweiten Mal in diesem Jahr, wo ich durch meine sehr nuschelige Aussprache, den Pada-Cast mal kurz zum Bada-Cast gemacht habe. Nein, Baden-Württemberg hat hier heute nichts verloren. Hallo, Kevin.
Da gab es eine Wahl. Ja, hi, Grüße. Gehen raus an alle Zuhörer und Zuhörerinnen.
Also, ihr seht schon, nicht nur die Liga ist Chaos, auch hier ist so ein bisschen Chaos mit dabei, aber wir passen uns einfach an. So wie das manchmal bei Hunden und hier ein Herrchen ist, ist das jetzt einfach mit dem Podcast und seiner Liga sowas. Kennt ihr das nicht, dieses Sprichwort? Das ist ein Herrchen und also, beziehungsweise Besitzer und ihre Hunde.
Das sieht gleich aussehen.
Voll oft gleich aussehen.
Ja, doch, das kenne ich. Aber es ist auch echt, es stimmt auch.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Also, es gibt einfach so bestimmte Hunde, da sieht man einfach, wer hat sich jetzt am wem orientiert. Wie rum war es jetzt? Na ja, zurück zum wichtigen Teil dieses Podcasts, nämlich dem Fußball. Und wir haben uns für insgesamt drei Partien entschieden, um stellvertretend auf diesen Spieltag zu schauen. Insgesamt schauen wir also auf sechs Vereine. Ihr kennt das Prozedere schon ein bisschen. Aber bevor wir das tun, wollen wir erst einmal kurz schauen, was denn sonst an diesem Spieltag so passiert ist. Und ich gehe mal davon aus, Kevin, dass dich vor allem das Spiel deiner Paderborner ja mehr oder weniger gut unterhalten hat am Wochenende.
Ach ja, das davor, der eine Woche, war echt schön, um darüber zu sprechen und das davor auch. Aber ja, das Klassiker gegen Braunschweig, finde ich, ist immer in meinem Kopf abgespeichert, dass das mega hässliche Spiele sind. Das war es auch irgendwie. Wobei der SCP ja, glaube ich, 14 Torschüsse abgegeben hat, aber die waren jetzt unter uns gesprochen auch nicht. Alles Top-Chancen. Braunschweig hat, glaube ich, einmal aufs Tor geschossen gefühlt. Nein, zweimal. Und halt ein Tor gemacht, geht in Führung. Und dann am Ende hast du aus Pallabrauner Sicht zumindest noch den Punkt erzwungen. Ich glaube 90 plus 8 gefühlt.
Ja, genau. Es war auf jeden Fall sehr spät.
Der Oldie Sven-Michel, das hat mich besonders gefreut.
Er ist, glaube ich, damit auch direkt in der Kicker-Elf des Tages gelandet, wenn ich mich daran richtig erinnere, an das, was ich heute so alles durchgeblinkt habe. Aber generell, wir hatten in der letzten Folge so ein bisschen darüber geredet, auch weil wir ja viel durch dich mitbekommen haben, dass zwischendurch so die Stimmung trotz zum Teil okayer Ergebnisse– also du warst, glaube ich, zwischendurch nicht so ganz zufrieden mit den Leistungen immer. Aber jetzt muss man ja sagen, Platz drei der Formtabelle mit acht Punkten aus den letzten vier Spielen und eben auch dieses Spiel dann nicht verloren. Da zeigt ja doch irgendwie, dass in der Mannschaft schon irgendwie der Wille da ist, bis zum Schluss mit dabei zu bleiben, oder nicht?
Ja, das ist definitiv so und das war auch gar kein Absprechen von Können oder von Wollen, sondern, dass man ja über ein paar Wochen, also über die Winterpause überbrückt, maximal eine Halbzeit gut gespielt hat, in Anführungsstrichen gut gespielt hat. Das ist ja auch von außen drauf geschaut. Der Trainer sieht das ja immer noch mal ein bisschen anders. Dann hast du das Spicking Hertha gehabt. Ja, das hat Marc nicht so gefreut, aber ich schon. Und Kaiserslautern, das waren zwei absolute Top-Spiele, Top-Leistungen. Gegen Braunschweig war es auch gut. Du musst eigentlich oder kannst nach 20 Minuten mindestens 1-0 führen. Und wenn du das Ding machst, jetzt kommt wieder so ein phrasenspheren Ding, dann ist der Knoten geplatzt und dann wirst du das Teil wahrscheinlich ohne arrogant klingen zu wollen, 3-0 oder 3-1 nach Hause bringen. Ja, aber wie gesagt, für mich ein Klassiker gegen Braunschweig ist es immer schwer. Die bringen wenig fußballerisch mit. In den letzten Jahren. Und ja, sie haben es halt mit ihren Mitteln gut gemacht, sich hinten reingestellt hat der SCP. Immer wieder Probleme mit über die Jahre hinweg schon. Ja, aber du hast schon recht, Platz 4 jetzt gerade ein Punkt hinter Platz 2 und 3. Das ist ja sowieso wild in der 2. Liga. Letztes Jahr gewesen, dieses Jahr auch.
Ja, ich sage ja, Chaos für Braunschweig natürlich gleichzeitig, um das nicht komplett unter den Tisch zu lassen. Für die sieht es momentan gar nicht mal so gut aus. Also man hat jetzt aus den letzten fünf Spielen nur zwei Punkte holen können. Drei Niederlagen aus den letzten fünf Spielen eben. Das ist in der Formtabelle tatsächlich Platz 16 momentan. Und klar, es geht auch wieder, kann auch wieder bergauf gehen, aber man hatte ja zwischendurch eigentlich das Gefühl, sie hätten sich stabilisiert und Tabak aus. Und da wäre auch mal spielerisch was gegangen. Aber momentan reicht es einfach nicht, muss man leider so sagen. In zwei Wochen steht auch das Derby an. Und da muss man glaube ich sagen, in der Verfassung, in der Braunschweig gerade ist. Gut, gleichzeitig reden wir gleich noch ganz kurz über Hannover. Weiß man da auch noch nicht so ganz, was man von Hannover erwarten kann. Aber wäre das wahrscheinlich gerade auch aus Fan-Perspektive nochmal, ich sag mal so die feine Nail in the Coffin. Also so ein bisschen so der letzte Sargnagel, der vielleicht aus Braunschweigersicht dann auch gesagt wird, so ey Leute, also Abschiebskampf hier und da, aber mal so ein Derby-Sieg wäre auch ganz schön. Da bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt, wie da die Stimmung auch bleibt. Weil wie gesagt, man hat ja eigentlich das Gefühl, Buckhaus hat es doch irgendwie geschafft, da das Ruder wieder rumzureißen. Aber ja, so richtig nachhaltig, scheint es gerade nicht zu sein. Klar, man steht noch über den Strich, aber es ist im Punkt gleich mitführt auf 16. Und wir sehen ja momentan so ganz aufgeben, möchte da unten eigentlich niemand so richtig. Also ich glaube, wir haben in dieser Saison schon fünfmal die Prognose gesagt, ja, also da wird es jetzt nichts mehr. Also da, die sind jetzt einfach weg vom Fenster und die Vereine sagen immer so, nee, nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Thomas, du hast gerade auch gezückt.
Naja, scheinbar wir ja schon so ein bisschen die letzten Spiele, wenn man auf die letzten Spiele guckt. Ja, könnte besser laufen. Also es erinnert gerade sehr, sehr viel an die Hinrunde.
Ja, fair. Wir reden später natürlich auch noch über deine Magdeburger. Aber ein Verein, der es geschafft hat, momentan so ein bisschen wieder neue Energie zu sammeln, das es führt. Die haben nämlich in Hannover mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Führt jetzt mit drei Spielen ohne Niederlage, Punktgewinn gegen Schalke, Siege gegen Hannover und Bielefeld. Und gerade diese Punkte gegen Schalke und Hannover, das waren ja welche, die konnte man so nicht erwarten. Also ich habe sie so auf jeden Fall nicht erwartet, ehrlich gesagt. Da muss man sagen, sie stehen defensiv sehr, sehr viel stabiler, muss man einfach so sagen. Also diese Flut an Gegentoren, die hat erstmal aufgehört. Und es war jetzt nicht so, dass Hannover überhaupt nicht aufs Tor geschossen hätte am Wochenende. Aber da stand man um einige stabiler. Hannover gleichzeitig, also, weiß ich nicht, die habe ich anscheinend mal wieder zu viel gelobt. Wir hatten darüber spekuliert, was passiert. Und man muss einfach sagen, dieses Unentschieden gegen Dresden, dann gewinnt man zwar 1 zu 0 im Bielefeld, aber man muss eben auch sagen, dank eines Berechtigten, aber dank eines Elfmeters. Und ja, jetzt diese Niederlage gegen geführt. Und man muss auch einfach sagen, also gerade die Elfmeterquote bei Hannover. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diesen Elfmeter gesehen habt von Enzo Leopold, aber ich sag mal so, wäre ich Trainer oder Fan dieser Mannschaft und ich wüsste, meine Elfmeterquote, also sie liegt jetzt momentan bei 50 Prozent, 4 von 8 Elfmetern verschossen oder verwandelt, je nachdem, wie man es erzählen muss. Glas halb voll, Glas halb leer in dem Falle. Das ist, also so lockerflockig in der Mitte schießen. Also wenn du in der Mitte schießt, musst du sowieso schon wirklich dir ganz sicher sein, dass das Ding reingeht. Aber das, also weiß ich nicht. Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber ich finde bei den Hannoveranern merkt man ganz doll, dass Bogus Tomiak eben hinten in der Kette fehlt. Also hat sich glaube ich nach dem Spiel gegen Dresden verletzt oder im Spiel gegen Dresden. Und da fehlt einfach diese, diese Stabilisierung und eben auch jemand, der eben das Spiel nach vorne antreibt. Wie gesagt, sie sind nicht chancenlos nach vorne, aber die Chancenverwertung von Hannover, sie ist es nicht. Thomas, du hast im Vorgespräch gesagt, es ist wieder die Titszeit, die Tits-Symptome, die du dich erinnern kannst. Wie schaust du auf Hannover?
Mir kommt das alles sehr bekannt vor. Christian Titz schafft es irgendwie immer wieder, wirklich grandiose Serien zu starten, im positiven Sinne, aber dann eben auch grandiose Serien im negativen Sinne zu starten. Also es ist wirklich selten, dass er mal mit seiner Mannschaft sechs, sieben Spiele am Stück ohne Nierlage bleibt. Das ist immer so vier, fünf Siege, dann sagt jeder, oh gucke. Da muss man aber glaube ich bei Hannover auch ein bisschen relativieren. Die hatten von den Siegen, die sie jetzt geholt haben, das waren ja alles Gegner aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte. Gut, jetzt war Föhrt natürlich auch aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte, aber zum Rückrunden auf hatten sie ja gegen KSL verloren. Das war eine Mannschaft von weiter oben oder aus dem Mittelfeld. Dann kamen ja grundsätzlich erst mal nur Mannschaften, die gegen den Abstieg spielen. Ich bin gespannt, wie das da weitergeht, wenn es dann wirklich gegen Caliber, wie eben Paderborn zum Beispiel geht, wie das dann in Hannover aussieht. Von daher bin ich da echt gespannt, ob Christian Tietz das genauso schafft wie bei uns. Auch diese Elfmeter-Thematik, das war bei uns genau das Gleiche. Ich weiß nicht, ob es an ihm liegt oder an den Spielern. Ich kann es echt nicht sagen. Aber wir hatten unter ihm auch eine unterirdische Strafstoßquote, die lag, glaube ich, sogar bei unter 50 Prozent bei uns. Das ist schon faszinierend. Ich bin echt gespannt, wie das da weitergeht, wenn es dann eben gegen die wirklich großen Caliber der Liga geht, wenn man da von Darmstadt, Schalke, Paderborn sprechen, wie es dann aussieht.
Es ist wirklich wild, dass die so eine Elferquote haben. Ich meine, ein Fußballprofi, in der Regel, also du baust jetzt keinen Trainer, der eben das beibringt oder so. Das ist ja in der Regel normalerweise, können die das ja und wenn sie es nicht können, schießen sie nicht. Also das ist irgendwie schon strange, vor allem wenn du sagst, dass das bei euch ähnlich war. Weil der Titz kann ja aber schwer an dem Coach liegen.
Da kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube, dass es immer so ist, wenn ich ruck sitze.
Aber der stellt sich immer ins Tor. Bei den Elfmeter-Übungen stellt sich Titz einfach ins Tor.
Aber das Programm hat es in sich von Hannover, ne?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und ich kann sagen, in Bielefelds erster Drittligasaison hatte man, glaube ich, auch nur eine 60-prozentige Quote vom Elfmeter-Punkt. Man muss halt einfach immer sagen, es ist immer noch was anderes, wenn du gegen den Abstieg spielst. Weil so ein Elfmeter kann dich dann natürlich noch mal anders nach vorne bringen. Aber eben ehrlich gesagt auch jetzt, also ich meine, zu Recht wurde auch schon kritisiert, dass man zu sehr auf die– oder dass ich auch zum Teil zu sehr auf die Expected-Goals-Tabelle gucke. Aber ich glaube, bei Anova sollten, glaube ich, irgendwie zehn Tore mehr haben oder so. Und wenn du daran mal alleine vier berechnest für die Elfmeter-Tore, das ist schon echt eine Nummer, weil also ein Elfmeter-Tor hat ja einfach einen sehr hohen XG-Wert. Das ist halt einfach statistisch gesehen so. Vielleicht gibt es beiden eigenen nur Elfmeter-XG-Wert für Anova. Wir bleiben gespannt.
Ja, plus sie haben ja immer sehr enge Spiele. Das heißt, es sind auch Momentum-Killer, also offenbar, die die Mannschaft sonst nochmal in eine ganz andere Richtung hätten pushen können. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie 0-3 zurückgelegen haben oder 3-0 geführt haben, als sie den, ne, so.
Ja, ich erinnere mich auch an das 0-0 gegen Bochum, wo Kellmann ja auch den Elfmeter verschießt. Das sind alles so Punkte, wo du dich hinterher vielleicht fragen könntest, was wäre wenn, ne? Und das ist natürlich immer enorm bitter, gleichzeitig führt. Also, Dank an meine Mannschaft, die war anscheinend Aufbauhilfe für die Spielvereinigung. Ja, das war auch ein ganz furchtbares Fußballspiel, aber da hast du eben gesehen, wenn du so ein Spiel warst, ganz ehrlich, das hätte auch 0-0 ausgehen können, so furchtbar war das. Aber sie nutzen halt ihre Konter aus, sie nutzen ihre Möglichkeiten aus, die sie haben. Und man muss sagen, du merkst irgendwie, dass zum Beispiel auch ein Silas Brüffrock, der ja auch, also gerade die Torhüterposition war ja ein ganz großes Problem bei den Viertern, der wirkte ganz anders, auch motiviert. Also du siehst halt, da wurde auch gegen Hannover, da wurde jede Verteidigungsaktion, die wurde richtig gefeiert. Und das macht natürlich auch einen Unterschied, gerade im Abstiegskampf, wenn du dann siehst, okay, es geht gerade doch irgendwie nach oben, also in der Tabelle. Da bin ich tatsächlich sehr gespannt und ich glaube, ich spreche, also liebe Grüße an Michi, aber wir waren alle der festen Überzeugung, die sind weg, also die sind wirklich weg vom Fenster.
Nach dem Spiel gegen Magdeburg habe ich gesagt, sie sind tot. Auch wie sie dann in den Interviews aufgetreten sind danach, das war wie so ein Abgesang. Da habe ich gedacht, okay, das sieht richtig, richtig bitter aus, entführt. Nach dem 4-5 war das, glaube ich. Ja, genau, das habt ihr nach 5. Und dann haben sie den Kasselslauter noch knapp verloren, das war aber auch verloren. Und dann dachte ich, okay, was soll da noch kommen? Ja, gut, dann kann das Spiel gegen euch.
Ja, ja, super.
Die haben aus diesen wirklich, ich sage mal, diesen Katastrophalen 20 Minuten gegen uns, haben die echt ihre Lärm gezogen. Also das war ja wirklich, das war ja, also ich habe auch gedacht, was ist denn das überhaupt? Das ist ja nicht mehr drittligatauglich, was die da hinten gespielt haben. Und haben aber offenbar die richtigen Lärm gezogen, haben, wie du schon sagst, Kevin, du bist ja nicht derjenige, den du gewonnen hast, sondern knapp verloren, dann gegen Bielefeld eben gewonnen. Und dann jetzt zwei Spiele, drei Spiele glaube ich, auf jeden Fall.
Schalke hat einen Punkt geholt, genau, und jetzt gewonnen.
Also die haben offenbar aus diesem Spiel wirklich die richtigen Lärm gezogen und sind jetzt wieder da, ja. Und Prospekt. Also ich hätte auch nach dem Spiel gegen uns, hätte ich auch gesagt, wobei die natürlich auch ein bisschen Pech hatten, wenn der Neuenberger da nicht auf der Linie klärt, geht das Spiel 5-5 aus und das Spiel auch ganz anders. Aber es war schon...
Die Interviews danach, die waren so, die waren ratlos, die waren völlig am Boden zerstört. Das war so der Klassik von einer Mannschaft, die jetzt wirklich, wirklich fertig ist.
Ja, aber ich muss sagen, ich war entführt natürlich, habe ich mir das grandiose Spiel auch noch live im Stadion angeguckt. Das war super. Aber du hast irgendwie gemerkt, da ist ein richtiger Ruck auch durch das ganze Stadion gegangen. Du hast es nach dem 2.1. gemerkt, das hat richtig was freigesetzt. Und wenn das tatsächlich, also wir sprechen so häufig davon, dass so ein Funka auch mal übersetzen kann, und wenn du das mal gemerkt hast, 90 Minuten, okay, da ist noch was drin und das Stadion lebt noch und die Fans leben noch, dann kann das schon nochmal ordentlich pushen, glaube ich. Und das hat man eben getan. Und man muss eben sagen, zum Beispiel gegen Bielefeld haben sie es halt auch wirklich geschafft. Ich glaube, Bielefeld hatte keine einzige Torchance wirklich aus dem Spieler heraus, weil sie es einfach ganz gut geschafft haben. Die Spieler, die eben Ziel bringt, für den Bielefelder Angriff sind und für eben das aus dem Spieler raus, die hat komplett rausgenommen. Und ich meine, da muss man sagen, also fast ja noch bitter, dass, ich meine, Edin Dzeko macht noch ein eigenes Tor gegen Führer, wird dann wegen der Abseits-Stellung noch zurückgenommen. Aber auch da siehst du, du hast Schalke auch richtig gestresst. Die wiederum, they took it personally, dass ich sie hier letztes Mal kritisiert habe. Also auch die. Da habe ich gedacht, also irgendwie fehlt mir da so ein bisschen was. Sie haben jetzt 10 Punkte aus den letzten vier Spielen, drei Siege und einen Unentschieden. Generell verlor Schalke bisher erst einmal nach Führung. Einmal konnte man nur Unentschieden spielen. Aus 17 Führungen entsprangen 15 Siege, unter anderem der 1.0 Siege gegen Bielefeld am Freitagabend, wo man einfach sagen muss, Edi Gico halt. Er steht dann nach einem Fehler des Bielefeldertorhüters, komplett richtig. Und dann musste man zwar zittern. Ich hatte Gali Grü an der Stelle, hatte zwei Schalker Frauen vor mir in der Schlange stehen zur Toilette und die diskutierten dann auch ein bisschen darüber, dass man nach den ersten 15 Minuten sich so ein bisschen zu, also dachte so, oh, was wird das? Aber das hat man eben überstanden und auch das spricht natürlich für die, also man hat diese Stabilität jetzt eben auch zurückgewonnen und es läuft jetzt auch wieder besser. Und special shout out, es wurde am Freitag eine Pause gemacht für die fastenbrechenden Spieler bei Schalke. Das waren, glaube ich, drei oder vier Stück. Da hatten die Vereine sich vorher drauf verkündet. Kleiner Tipp an Schalke, so was vielleicht mal anzeigen, dass das jetzt passiert. Wir waren alle sehr verwirrt, warum an einem Freitagabend bei 10 Grad es eine Trinkpause gab. Und wenn du noch so in der letzten Reihe in diesem Stadion sitzt, weißt du nicht sofort, was da abgeht. Vielleicht einfach so ein kurzer Hinweis auf den Stadion. Es wird super, wenn ihr helfen. Aber sonst finde ich das tatsächlich eine gute Entwicklung im Fußball, auch im deutschen Fußball, dass darauf Rücksicht genommen wird auf Spieler, die den Ramadan feiern und das Fastenbrechen bei Abendspielen vollziehen wollen. Gut, wir hatten auch noch einige Freak-Spiele, ehrlich gesagt. Bochum, Kaiserslautern, Dresden gegen Karlsruhe. Aber ich glaube, sonst reden wir hier noch eine halbe Stunde weiter über den ganzen Spieltag. Daher würde ich vorschlagen, wir starten rein ins Spiel 1. Ich sage einmal kurz, es war Darmstadt gegen Kiel. Darmstadt gewinnt in Überzahl mit 2 zu 0 gegen Tim Walters Kieler. Dabei können die Kieler in der ersten Halbzeit die Null halten und eigentlich auch ganz gut mithalten, bis allerdings Marius Müller innerhalb von 10 Minuten erst die gelbe und dann die gelb-rote Karte von Schiedsrichter Dennis Eidigin gezeigt bekommt. Isaac Liedberg trifft das erste Mal seit dem 18. Spieltag wieder und bringt die Ligien in der 48. Minute in Führung. Niklas Schmidt kann nur 4 Minuten später einen Fehler der Kieler zum Doppelschlag nutzen. Lasst uns zuerst auf die Darmstädter gucken. Es ist Platz 2, es sind 48 Punkte. 47 zu 28 Tore, 13 Siege, 9 Unentschieden und 3 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle in den letzten vier Spielen, da steht man schon ganz gut da auf Platz 4, 7 Punkte sind es daraus, 2 Siege, 1 Unentschieden, 1 Niederlage. Bevor wir gleich auf Darmstadt zu sprechen kommen, habe ich noch eine Sache, bevor ich die nämlich hinterher vergesse. Am 8. März, also gestern, und uns ausgesehen, war der feministische Kampftag und wir wissen alle, dass vor allem der Männerfußball nicht immer besonders viel Raum für die Geschichten von Frauen im Fußball übrig lässt. Umso schöner fand ich es tatsächlich, dass die aktive Fanszene der Darmstädter am Samstag an Luise Büchner erinnert hat, die Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts für Frauenrechte in der Darmstädter Region gekämpft hat und an der Stelle auch Shout-out an die fürhörte Ultraszene. Die hatte einen Banner, worauf stand Frauenrechte statt Blumenstreuserschluss mit Symbolpolitik. Ich finde das tatsächlich sehr ermutigend, dass so was aus den Fanszenen herauskommt und bei allem Respekt nicht irgendeine Marketing-Aktion vom Verein ist. So was finde ich in vielen Bereichen tatsächlich manchmal ein bisschen unangenehm. Besten wir noch das Wort Frauenpower oder Powerfrau oder so. Dabei steht da schüttelts mich ehrlich gesagt immer ziemlich. Aber Thomas, nach der Niederlage gegen Dresden am vergangenen Spieltag konnte man jetzt eben gegen einen Abstiegskandidat von unten wieder drei Punkte einfahren. Wie schaust du denn momentan auf Darmstadt?
Stark, also ich finde das, was Darmstadt da unter Kohfeldt in dieser Saison spielt, das macht Spaß. Also ich gucke die Darmstädter Spiele wirklich, wenn ich sie gucken kann, sehr, sehr gerne. Das ist ein klarer Plan. Die Mannschaft kann gut verteidigen. Die Mannschaft kann gut mit Ball auch inzwischen nach vorne spielen. Sie ist bei Standard Situationen gefährlich. Also das ist alles so ein Gesamtpaket, was mir persönlich sehr gefällt. Und ich glaube, diese Niederlage in Dresden, glaube ich, auch muss man vielleicht auch ein bisschen... Ja, ich fand Darmstadt gar nicht schlecht. Also das war vom Spielverlauf, würde ich sagen, eher kein 3-1. Das war schon auch... Also ich glaube, Dresden-Rock kann sich nicht beklagen, wenn Darmstadt dann mit einem Punkt nach Hause geht. Nichtsdestotrotz war es ein verdienter Dresdner Sieg. Und Serien sind ja dafür da, um gebrochen zu werden. Und ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass die Darmstädter Serie noch ein bisschen geht und ein bisschen später gebrochen wird. Leider Gottes ist es gegen Dresden dann passiert. Und ich glaube, das hat bei denen auch nochmal so ein bisschen vielleicht nochmal die Sinne geschärft, zu sagen, Mensch, es geht eben doch nicht alles von alleine. Und ich glaube, 13 Spiele waren es, glaube ich, die sie nicht verloren hatten. Das waren es schon ein paar und das macht, glaube ich, schon was im Kopf mit dir. Und irgendwann wirst du vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen nachlässiger. Und da war diese Nierlage natürlich für Darmstadt, glaube ich, so blöd, die war goldwert. Und die sind jetzt wieder in der Spur. Ich fand schon, Kiel war gerade im Pressing. Also man kennt man ja von Tim Walther dann auch dieses hohe Pressing. Da hatten sie schon ein bisschen Probleme, haben sich da aber gut rausgespielt am Ende. Und dann, meiner Meinung nach, auch das Spiel völlig verdient mit 12. Runden. Also ich gucke schon mit sehr viel Neid nach Darmstadt gerade, weil das macht echt Spaß, die zu gucken.
Sie haben einfach die beste Offensive der Liga. Meistens Dore auch noch Standards, 15 insgesamt. Also sie haben eben natürlich auch eine Qualität vom Außenspiel heraus und nach Kontern. Aber eben auch, wenn alles mal nicht läuft, dann sind die Standards auch immer noch da. Und man muss natürlich sagen, Kevin, endlich hat mal wieder Isak Liedberg getroffen. Der hatte ja, wenn man vorsichtig sagen will, so als Stürmer schon so eine kleine Formkrise drin. Hat eben einige Spieltage, wo er auch einfach unglücklich wirkt, ehrlich gesagt. Gleichzeitig Fraser Hornby, der eben ausfällt wegen Oberschenkelproblemen. Da muss man sagen, jetzt stand er aber, macht eben das Tor zum 1-0, leitet den Sieg ein. Und ja, muss man glaube ich sagen, ist jetzt gerade für den Endspurt für ihn auch sehr, sehr wichtig, da wieder reinzukommen.
Ja, absolut. Und also überhaupt für die Mannschaft, die Garanten quasi der Toremaschine, dass sie wieder in Schwung kommen zum Endprogramm, sodass wir hoffentlich auch am letzten Spieltag dann das Finale gegen den SC Paderborn in Darmstadt. Nein, absolut. Also, Lidbergh, absoluter Toregarant. Und ich müsste jetzt lügen, aber ich habe mir schon gedacht, dass der nochmal in der Rückrunde jetzt wieder loslegen würde. Klar, wenn der kongeniale Partner auch weg ist und so weiter und so fort, man kennt das dann. Thomas hatte gerade von der Serie gesprochen. Das war ja auch eine Art Serie. Wenn die dann auch bricht, dann ist erst mal so diese Über-Pacing ist dann erst mal weg. Dann ist man wieder so bei den 100 Prozent, schon nicht bei 150 oder so. Ja, insofern. Aber ich habe es die letzten Mal auch mit Matthias schon gesagt. Darmstadt für mich absoluter haushoher Favorit auf den Aufstieg. Es sind nicht Erste, aber das ist dem geschuldet, dass Schalke halt viele knappe Dinge eingefahren hat und Darmstadt jetzt einfach auswärts mal geschwächelt hat. Zweimal. Drei Niederlagen erst. Klar, neun Unentschieden, aber drei Niederlagen ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Ja, und sie verlieren vor allem zu Hause nicht. Also ich glaube in dieser Saison sowieso komplett ungeschlagen zu Hause.
Das ist im letzten Spieltag dann.
Also 33 der 48 Punkte zu Hause geholt. Das spricht eine sehr, sehr deutliche Sprache tatsächlich. Ich bin ja tatsächlich froh, dass sie dann zu Aminia reisen müssen. Das Spiel gegen sie handeln wir ja schon. Aber ja, also du merkst ja noch einfach, dass das entwickelt sich dann von selber bei denen. Also da schießen sie das 1-0. Ich fand übrigens, Niedler Schmidt kam ja erst im Winter zu den Darmstädtern. Gerade in dem Spiel, finde ich, hat er ein wahnsinnig gutes Spiel gemacht. Nicht nur durch sein Tor. Was ich tatsächlich gut fand, also ich glaube, sowohl Schmidt als auch Vukotic haben gelb gesehen. Wegen Meckerns. Vukotic, weil er eben die gelb-rote Karte forderte für Marius Müller. Das ist sowieso was, was ich überhaupt nicht leiden kann. Also lass den Thierry die Situation doch erstmal bewerten. Und dann schauen wir mal, da gab es eben Gelbführer. Und ich glaube, Schmidt, weil er auch so gemerkt hat, da hatte Aytekin eine sehr klare Linie. Sonst in der faulen Bewertung kann man tatsächlich, glaube ich, fast darüber diskutieren, ob die gelbe, also die zweite gelbe Karte dann im Endeffekt gepasst hat. Die erste gelbe war eben auch Meckerei von Müller. Von daher muss man dann, muss man selber wissen, ob man so eine Karte kassieren möchte. Aber ja, also ich glaube, wir haben über Darmstadt schon so viel Positives gesagt in dieser Saison und es ist, ich sage es auch gerne immer wieder, ich hätte es tatsächlich nicht gedacht, dass Florian Kohfeldt es tatsächlich schafft, diese Mannschaft so zu entwickeln. Und du siehst eben, also sie profitieren natürlich auch einfach von dem ruhigen Umfeld, wobei Schalke vielleicht doch dann nach diesen Paar Spielen, wo du dann doch gemerkt hast, ah, da läuft nicht alles rund, so ein bisschen die Unruhe, vielleicht beim, oder was heißt Unruhe, aber natürlich dann geht der Kopf an und du hast Schiss, ach, wenn wir es jetzt verspielen und so. Und das ist bei Darmstadt einfach gar nicht. Also das betonen die Fans ja auch immer, da sind man, man ist sich komplett im Reinen mit Fans und Mannschaften und Vereinen und der Vereinsführung, das läuft schon sehr gut.
Und plus sie können, und das ist einfach immer wieder ein Riesen-Faust-Fantastik, weiß man, oder stellt Profimannschaften durchaus, dass sie mehrere Systeme spielen können, können, sollten. Aber Darmstadt kriegt es halt echt hin. Also Kohlfeld hat ja in der Halbzeit noch dann umgestellt, auf Viererkette. Und dadurch, ja, weiß nicht, Kiel dann ist damit nicht klargekommen und hat die Situation nicht so schnell attestipieren können und hat sich dann innerhalb von fünf Minuten die zwei Dinger gefangen, weil es einfach eine ganz andere Spielveranlagung und Dynamik auf einmal war, um die Kieler so ein bisschen aufzustoßen, die Kieler-Defensive. Ja, das ist schon top, wenn eine Mannschaft das in der Lage ist, während des Spiels so ein System umzustellen und das dann auch die Kette kriegt. Das ist immer ein großes Zeichen, ein gutes Indiz dafür, dass die oben bleiben. Ich bin da ganz bei Thomas. Das ist schon– und bei dir auch. Das hat Kohlfeld sehr gut weiterentwickelt, die Mannschaft. Und ich bin mir felsenfest sicher, dass die aufsteigen werden.
Ich bin jetzt Freitag auswärts in Magdeburg. Thomas guckt schon gespannt drauf. Und dann haben wir eben das Duell gegen Schalke. Also das könnte tatsächlich ein sehr entscheidendes Duell generell um die Tabellenführung, aber generell auch um die Ausstiegsplätze werden. Und da auch ganz interessant, weil im Pokal konnte Darmstadt ja 4 zu 0 gegen Schalke gewinnen. In der Liga verloren man das Spiel fünf Tage zuvor. In der Liga, klar, das war eben auswärts. Aber da muss man schon sagen, das wird, glaube ich, ein durchaus spannendes Spiel. Wahrscheinlich geht es 0-0 aus, weil alle wieder drüber reden werden. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Darmstadt das verliert in der Verfassung, in der sie dann sind, so wie sie eben auch auftreten in vielen Spielen. Mal schauen, was wir da auch von Schalke her sehen können bei dem Spiel. Da kommen mit zwei sehr unterschiedlichen Spielveranlagungen wieder aufeinander. Weil wir eben schon zwei Spiele in der Hinrunde hatten, wo man eben gesehen hat, in welche Richtung es gehen kann. Von daher bin ich da mal sehr, sehr gespannt. Gleichzeitig haben wir eben die Kieler. Die sind jetzt auf Platz 17 abgerutscht. 25 Punkte, 29 zu 37 Tore, 6 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 12 Niederlagen in der Fond. In der Formtabelle. Ich musste eben auch noch mal nachgucken. Platz 17, ein Unentschieden, drei Niederlage. Nach der Niederlage gegen Karlsruhe am 23. Spieltag, was ja vorher schon als großes Welcher Trainer, welchen Trainer jetzt sein Treffenspiel deklariert wurde, entließ man Marcel Rapp nach viereinhalb Jahren und holte Tim Walter zurück zur KSV. Der war schon 2018, 2019 schon mal Chef-Trainer. So wie ich es gelesen habe, waren nicht alle Fans so super davon überzeugt, dass man ihn zurückholt. Einfach, weil er damals ja, ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen, für größere Aufgaben oder für größere Vereine die KSV verlassen hat. Und ja, wir wissen alle, wie es beim ASV lief. Aber im Heimspiel gegen Elversberg, das ist ja ins 1 ausgegangen, da gab es erstmal viele dankende Spruchbänder aus der Kieler Fanszene an Marcel Rapp und auch Tim Walter hat sich sehr, der kennt Marcel Rapp auch noch, sehr lobend über ihn geäußert. Und man muss sagen, diese ersten beiden Spiele unter Walter, da hat man, wie ich finde, schon ein bisschen was an Walter Beil gesehen, ehrlich gesagt. Also einmal diese ja doch durchaus Körperlichkeit, die da manchmal ein bisschen mit reinspielt, aber tatsächlich auch gute fußballerische Ansätze. Man konnte gegen Elversberg einen Rückstand schnell egalisieren. Hier muss man sagen, hat man 25 Minuten, ist ja schon auch geschafft, gut gegen Darmstadt zu stehen. Am Ende hat es halt nicht gereicht. Dazu gehört aber auch Felares, der fehlte gegen Darmstadt. Dafür konnte Bernardsson nach langer Verletzungspause, ich glaube drei Monate war der raus, gegen Elversberg wieder spielen. Sowieso hat Steven Skripski ja ein Muskelbünneres, der fällt seit einem Monat aus. Offensiv fehlen da vor 29 Toren zumindest gerade sechs. Also ist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel, aber da fehlt eben offensiv auch so ein bisschen was. Thomas, ich sage ehrlich, ich dachte nicht, dass sie da noch mal so tief reinrutschen. Ich gucke sowieso nicht mehr auf die Tabelle meistens, weil dann kriege ich meistens schlechte Laune. Aber als ich dann noch mal so drauf geguckt habe, boah, Platz 17, das zeigt eben, wie schnell es gehen kann. Was ist das allergrößte Problem, was die Kieler gerade haben?
Boah, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, Kiel ist das ganz große Problem. Alle anderen, die da unten stehen, wussten, was passiert. Kiel wahrscheinlich nicht. Die haben, glaube ich, nicht damit gerechnet. Und den Schalter umzulegen im Kopf, das kann dauern. Und das dauert schon ganz schön lange bei denen. Und ich glaube, Düsseldorf hat es zum Beispiel geschafft, jetzt unter Anfang diesen Schalter umzulegen. In Kiel muss man gucken, ob das unter Walter funktioniert. Also ich glaube schon, dass der Walter als Typ einfach so ein bisschen Druck auch von der Mannschaft nehmen kann, einfach durch seine Art. Der wird wahrscheinlich medial doch schon ein bisschen Interesse auf sich lenken. Aber ob das dann am Ende reichen wird, wobei man natürlich sagen muss, er hatte jetzt auch das große Problem mit Elbersberg und Darmstadt, natürlich auch mit zwei Krachern anzufangen. Das ist natürlich auch sehr, sehr undankbar. Ich glaube, die werden ihre Punkte gegen die Mannschaften, gegen die direkte Konkurrenz holen. Dafür ist die individuelle Qualität von Kiel einfach auch zu groß. Und wenn Walter es schafft, seinen Fußball da zumindest in Ansätzen reinzubringen, dann denke ich auch, dass Kiel am Ende die nötigen Punkte holen wird und eben nicht amsteigen wird. Aber sie müssen eben auch, glaube ich, im Kopf dahin kommen, dass ihnen bewusst ist, dass es jetzt wirklich nur noch ohne Klassenerhalt geht und um nichts anderes mehr. Und das ist für mich die Frage, ob sie das schaffen.
Also ich weiß, dass es immer so ein blöder Vergleich ist, aber Kevin, du kennst das ja von Paderborn auch. Ich glaube, es ist eben als Absteiger sehr schwierig zum Teil, egal wie lange du jetzt Bundesliga gespielt hast, ob das drei Jahre waren, ob das ein Jahr waren, oder wie auch immer. Weil dir alle immer sagen, ja deine individuelle Klasse, die ist eigentlich viel zu hoch dafür und eigentlich hast du ja auch gute Ansätze und eigentlich solltest du da unten nicht stehen.
Der Kader-Marktwert von Kiel vor der Saison, haben alle gesagt, das ist mit der teuerste Kader vom Marktwert her. Ja, kennen wir alle. Das ist– Bochum hat das auch erlebt. Bremen, als sie damals abgestiegen sind, haben sie auch in der hinteren Runde richtig Probleme gehabt. In der dritten Liga siehst du es jetzt auch bei bestimmten Teams. Die Ulm, guck dir Ulm an, gehen wahrscheinlich komplett durch.
So 1000 letzte Saison durchgeflogen.
Ja, genau. Also das ist tatsächlich so ein Phänomen. Ich habe mich wirklich erschrocken. Ich habe auch Kiel länger nicht beobachtet. Als ich jetzt dann in der Versendungsvorbereitung auf die Tabelle geguckt habe und gesehen habe, dass die auf 17 stehen und erst 25 Punkte haben und den letzten Sieg, den sie geholt haben, gegen den Estée-Parlabon war, also am ersten Rückrundenspieltag, wo sie schon unfassbar schlecht gespielt haben und trotzdem gewonnen haben, wo ich mich damals gefragt habe, wie ihnen das gelungen ist. Das habe ich, glaube ich, auch in dieser Sendung gesagt damals, so ungefähr wortlautmäßig. Ich habe die ganze Zeit überlegt, ob der Zeitpunkt des Trainerwechsels gut war. Vielleicht war er das, weil er jetzt zwei Spiele hatte, wo er die Mannschaft, wie du sagst, so wieder reinbringen kann. Weil jetzt kommen die Teams, alle nur noch, die in Anführungsstrichen natürlich nur noch, die unten mit in der Verlosung sind. Also Kiel kann jetzt die Big Points einfahren in den nächsten Wochen. Ja, also was haben wir noch? Nürnberg, Bochum. Bochum ist aber auch ganz gut drauf inzwischen. Münster, Düsseldorf, Lautern, Hertha. Für die geht es dann nicht mehr um viel wahrscheinlich. Ja, mal gucken. Aber es ist schon heftig. Also wenn die am Ende ein Finale gegen Braunschweig oder Magdeburg haben, boah, da werde ich aber auch nicht an der Seitenlinie stehen.
Saisonfinale in Magdeburg kann ich als Absteiger aus der Bundesliga absolut überhaupt nicht empfehlen.
Ich spiele zu Hause gegen Magdeburg und im letzten Spieltag dann in Dresden. Uiuiui, also…
Ja, also das ist eben das Problem. Dafür ist in dieser Liga– also zu dem Zeitpunkt werden wir vielleicht doch noch ein, zwei Teams haben, für die es um nichts mehr geht, aber momentan– wir sagen es immer wieder– besteht dieses Mittelfeld aus Kaiserslautern und Hertha. So, das sind die zwei Teams, für die es gerade um die goldene Ananas wortwörtlich eigentlich noch geht. Und das ist– man muss halt leider einfach sagen– bei Kiel schwebt eben im Hintergrund noch ein großes Thema und das ist der Stadion-Umbau. Da stehen 75 Millionen Euro im Raum und das wurde auch im Forum genannt. Also ganz gelassen guckst du da, glaube ich, nicht drauf, wenn du Pläne hast, die du dir in der Bundesliga vielleicht so angefangen hast zu machen. Du dachtest ja, okay, 2. Liga wird nicht easy, aber dass du dich da jetzt mit dem Umbau in der 3. Liga beschäftigen musst, wo man einfach noch nicht weiß, wie entwickeln sich denn überhaupt die Zuschauer in den Zahlen in dieser 3. Liga. Und wir wissen alle, 3. Liga ist einfach kein geiles Pflaster, um sich gerade finanziell irgendwie gut aufzustellen. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Alleine wegen der wegfallenden TV-Gelder. Ja, also ich dachte...
Man ist immer hinter klüger. Ich hätte zum Saisonbeginn schon gemutmaßt, dass die den Kader intensiver durchwechseln hätten sollen. Weil das immer schwierig ist, eine Mannschaft, die abgestiegen ist, wo dann auch Spieler dabei sind, vielleicht, die nur wegen Bundesliga gekommen sind, dann auf die Kette zu kriegen, dass die 2. Liga und dann auch noch Abschiebskampf. Da Thomas ja vollkommen recht. Den Schalter musste dann auch erstmal bei jemandem umschalten, der wegen Bundesligafußball nach Kiel gekommen ist. Aber klar, hinterher ist man immer schlauer. Trotzdem, da... Das wird jetzt echt schwierig. Ich bin auch immer noch fasziniert, warum der Kollege Walther wieder dort ist. Dabei ist mir erst mal aufgefallen, dass er tatsächlich irgendwo einen anderen Job bekommen hat. Ich bin wirklich konzerniert gewesen vor dieser Sendung.
Ja, also man muss sagen, es ist ne... Ich sag ja eigentlich immer so schön aufgewärmt, es schmeckt ne Rulasch, aber ich verstehe aus rein taktischen Gründen schon ein bisschen, warum du es gemacht hast. Eben weil du so ein bisschen weißt, was du mit Tim Walther bekommen kannst. Und es geht halt gerade wirklich nur um den Klassenerhalt. Perspektivisch ist es für mich auch ein Fragezeichen, ehrlich gesagt. Ne, klar, und da verstehe ich eben auch jeden Fan, der da sehr, sehr skeptisch draufguckt. Man muss eben einfach sagen, ich glaube halt Steven Skripski als Kapitän, der fehlt halt nicht nur vielleicht als Spieler an sich, sondern eben auch vielleicht, ne, weil er eben verletzt ist, als Kapitän in so einer Phase. Ich glaube, dass das auch immer ein Punkt sein kann, ehrlich gesagt. Und, ne, ihr habt das Programm angesprochen, ne, so spielt ihr jetzt eben gegen Nürnberg. Ich würde auch langsam sagen, die können wir vielleicht so ganz vorsichtig langsam auch in dieses Sortiment goldene Ananas schicken. Mal schauen. Eben Bochum, Münster, gerade Münster, sprechen wir später auch noch drüber. Ähm, das, ja, und ich mein, man muss halt trotzdem sagen, dass, jetzt mal ausgeschlossen von Bochum wahrscheinlich, da viele Vereine natürlich immer noch hinreisen und andersrum, die sagen halt, ja gut, also, ihr macht mal erstmal als Absteiger, ne, uns relativ egal, wo ihr in der Tabelle steht und das ist eben die große Gefahr, wenn du dich da irgendwie nicht, äh, rausbrühen kannst und ich meine, trotzdem ist halt so eine Entscheidung mit dem Bundesligatrainer, der halt Historisches geschafft hat, nämlich Kiel das erste Mal in die Bundesliga zu führen. Ähm, das ist natürlich keine einfache Entscheidung und da muss man dann tatsächlich auch immer irgendwann fragen, richtiger Zeitpunkt, jetzt es erst zu machen, ähm, gleichzeitig muss man sagen, du hättest wahrscheinlich noch einen Punkt gehabt, wo es jetzt noch gegangen wäre später und das wäre die Länderspielpause gewesen. Also, ähm, der Vorteil ist, dass Walter das eben, der hat dann ein paar Spiele gesehen, hat dann zwei Wochen Zeit, vielleicht auch zu sagen, okay, fahrt erstmal drei Tage weg, nehmt euch irgendwie Zeit mit der Familie oder was auch immer und dann sehen wir uns dann und dann wieder und dann schwören wir uns noch mal zusammen. Da bin ich immer gespannt, was es da noch wird. Aber so ganz viel Zeit ist es eben nicht mehr, ne? Neun Spieltage sind jetzt noch zu gehen. Ähm, du, also man sagt ja, glaube ich, gerade, wenn alles so eng ist, so die letzten fünf Spieltage sind ja meistens die, wo es dann wirklich entscheidend wird. Wenn du in einer bestimmten Position bist, egal, ob es zum Ausstiegs- oder Abstiegskampf geht. Und das wird eben dann auch entscheidend sein, genau diese fünf Spieltage im Prinzip nach der Länderspielpause. Und ein paar mehr sind schon dann. Aber das wird eine große Story, glaube ich, für die Kieler noch.
Oh ja. Also der beste Tor-Schütz ist ein Abwehrspieler.
Das ist krass. Es fehlt halt, wie ich gesagt habe, 29 Tore. Das ist halt auch einfach wirklich nicht gut. Also das muss man leider einfach so deutlich sagen. Nur Braunschweig hat, glaube ich, weniger geschossen mit 28. Also dir fehlt einfach die Durchschlagskraft vorne. Das muss man leider einfach so sagen. Und da bin ich mal gespannt. Also ich kenne da noch so einen anderen Verein, der einfach gerade nicht in der Lage ist, Tore zu schießen. Und hinterher sagt man immer, Mama, wir haben doch gar nicht so schlecht gespielt. Ja, bringt dir hinterher leider einfach keine Punkte, wenn du hinten dann trotzdem die entscheidenden Fehler machst. Oder halt wie, also ich meine, im Endeffekt muss man einfach sagen, also ich verstehe Aydigens Entscheidung schon, Müller davon Platz zu stellen. Gerade wenn du Geld hast, würde ich vielleicht nicht so in einen Zweikampf reingehen. Das ist einfach, also ja. Und dann läuft halt die restlichen 75 Minuten in Unterzahl. Und dann ist, glaube ich, auch Tim Walters und das wissen wir aus seiner Hamburger Zeit einfach noch, dass das ja meistens schon eine Art Fußball ist, die auf so einen sehr genauen Plan A zugeschnitten ist. Und ihr habt es eben schon gesagt, mit der Systemumstellung da noch in der zweiten Hälfte. Da hast du gesehen, da ging dann halt ein, also ging auch Plan A ins B und C irgendwie nicht mehr auf. Und dann wird es natürlich immer schwierig. Und natürlich, gerade wenn du dich in dieser Situation befindest, ist natürlich auch valide, erst mal zu sagen, okay, wir brauchen jetzt ein System, was klappt. Aber das gehst du natürlich schon von aus, dass du was mit elf Spielern spielst und nicht, oder beziehungsweise mit neun, zehn Feldspielern und nicht nur mit neun. Gut, lasst uns ein Spiel weitergehen. Elversberg gegen Magdeburg, Elversberg gewinnt spät, aber insgesamt, ja, ich glaube, doch durchaus verdient. Die Magdeburger, die haben eigentlich eine gute erste Halbzeit gespielt oder eine okaye erste Halbzeit gespielt, aber Thema Effizienz war hier auch dabei. In der zweiten Halbzeit startet der FCM eigentlich ganz gut, aber auch da fehlt wieder das Tor. Die SVE übernimmt dann Stück für Stück die Spielkontrolle und erzielt dann zum Ende hin das 1 zu 0. Bleibt damit Darmstadt und Schalke auf den Fersen. Magdeburg beendet den Spieltag auf Platz 18. Lasst uns zuerst auf die SVE schauen. Platz 3 ist es. 48 Punkte, damit punktlich mit Darmstadt. 44 zu 26 Tore, 14 Siege, 6 Unentschieden und 5 Niederlagen vom Tabelle in den letzten vier Spielen. Platz 2, drei Siege, ein Unentschieden. Und das eben, muss man glaube ich trotzdem immer noch sagen, trotz des, ja, Verlustes des besten Stürmers der Elversberger mit Ebnut Talib. Kevin, ich meine, du schaust natürlich aus Paderborner Perspektive auch nach Elversberg, weil sie eben ein Konkurrent im Ausstiegskampf sind. Man muss glaube ich einfach sagen, das hat glaube ich auch Patrick Sander nach dem Spiel gesagt, das ist halt so ein Spiel, als Mannschaft obendrin gewinnst du das halt, als Mannschaft untendrin verlierst du es eben. Reicht das, um Elversberg in diesem Spiel oder momentan auch zu beschreiben?
Ich weiß, was er damit sagen will, gebe ich ihm durchaus recht aus eigener Erfahrung, als wir damals unten standen, kam mir das auch immer so vor, auch bei Elfmeter-Entscheidungen und Karten-Entscheidungen und so weiter und so fort. Also ich habe auch Elversberg– ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wann das war– zu Beginn der Rückrunde, glaube ich, als sie in Nürnberg verloren haben und dann nur einen Punkt gegen Bochengold haben, habe ich gedacht, okay, da ist der Ofen irgendwie aus, das wird nicht reichen, um dauerhaft da oben zu bleiben. Aber wie du sagst, respektabel, trotzdem Abgang des Knipsers, das nenne ich es jetzt mal, drei Tore in Lautern geschossen, drei Tore dann gegen Berlin kassiert, aber dann wieder in Dresden Reaktion direkt gezeigt und gegen Braunschweig, also insgesamt wieder fünf Tore geschossen. Und jetzt halt so ein Arbeitsstieg gegen Magdeburg. Und immer wenn du die ziehst, bist du eigentlich eine gesunde Mannschaft. Das habe ich bei Schalke auch gesagt, auch wenn es da nicht schön ist. Und vor allem die Fans des FCM teufelisch ärgern wird, weil ein Punkt in Elversberg wäre sicherlich ganz nett gewesen in der Situation. Ja, ich kann Elversberg schwer einschätzen, ob das letztendlich reichen wird, um dann so Spiele weiter oben– also gut, in Hannover ist das ein blödes Beispiel– aber dann das direkte Duell gegen Schalke zu gewinnen oder gegen Paderborn. Also Elversberg ist für mich komischerweise immer noch eine Wundertüte, obwohl sie am Anfang, also zum Beginn der Saison für mich, eine klar gesetzte Mannschaft für die Top 5 war. Also das haben sie ja bestätigt bisher, das wird ja auch nicht großartigmäßig verändern. Ja, haben eine ganz gute Form. Aber ich bin noch nicht so ganz überzeugt. Also ich glaube für die Top 3.
Ja, ich glaube, du hast es gerade schon mal so ein bisschen durch die Blume gesagt, der Spielplan wird tatsächlich, glaube ich, einfach interessant. Also man spielt jetzt als nächstes innenführt, dann zu Hause gegen Bielefeld, also zwei Vereine, die gegen den Abstieg spielen, dann eben Hannover und Schalke, dann Karlsruhe, wo man irgendwie auch ehrlich gesagt nie weiß, was man da gerade bekommt, dann eben Darmstadt, Paderborn und dann noch Düsseldorf und Münster hinten raus. Düsseldorf, kann man vielleicht sogar auch schon sagen, sind zu dem Zeitpunkt vielleicht auch durch mit der Saison und sie sich nicht mehr ganz dumm anstellen. Und dann eben noch Münster. Also du hast eben vielleicht die direkten Duelle gleichzeitig zu einer guten, als auch gegen einer ungünstigen Zeit. Weil eben so wie gegen Paderborn am 3. Mai, dann kann das schon nochmal sehr wegweisend werden für beide Vereine natürlich. Und da musst du dich bis dahin halt in eine gute Situation gebracht haben und bestmöglich natürlich die Spiele gegen Hannover und Schalke gut bestritten haben. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, wenn du die beiden Spiele nicht gewinnst, der wird richtig krass und da würde ich dann einfach mal vorsichtig die Prognose schon mal äußern, dann wird es schwierig. Also wenn du dann also die beiden Spiele dann noch nicht mal einen Punkt holst, dann würde ich fast sagen, ist er, je nachdem was Hannover noch so veranstaltet in den nächsten Wochen, könnte das fast zu sein. Aber gleichzeitig muss man natürlich auch immer mit einem ganz großen Ausrufezeichen sagen, das ist auch vollkommen okay. Also wir haben jetzt schon so oft gesagt, was die vor dieser Saison alles durchmachen mussten, dann Ebnut Alib noch in der Winterpause verloren, David Mock war, der als Ersatz gekommen ist, zumindest auch schon mit drei Toren zuletzt gegen Kiel und Braunschweig getroffen, also auch das klappt. Das ist Lukas Sporey war, der in dem Spiel getroffen hat. Du hast Petkov, der da auch immer seine Sachen macht. Der trifft irgendwie auch immer einer. Man hat jetzt den Platz als beste Offensive verloren, aber auch 44 Tore und dann eben auch eine sehr stabile Defensive am Ende des Tages. Die spielen halt ihren Stiefel runter und diese Last-Minute-Tore, die können dich halt auch gut weiterbringen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich gehe sonst mit dir mit, Kevin. Das ist schon so eine kleine Wundertüte am Ende des Tages. Thomas, möchtest du noch einen Satz zu Elbersberg sagen oder sollen wir auf deine Magdeburger schauen?
Naja, die holen halt aber auch die Punkte, die sie brauchen jetzt auch gegen die Mannschaft. Die haben gegen Dresden gewonnen, gegen Braunschweig gewonnen, gegen Kiel gepunktet, gegen uns jetzt gewonnen. Die Spiele, die sie gewinnen müssen, um oben dabei zu bleiben erstmal, die gewinnen sie. Und dann muss man gucken, wie es in den Direktuellen nachher läuft. Und ja, es ist für Elbersberg sicherlich ein krasser April, aber auch Hannover, Schalke und Darmstadt müssen auch erst mal gegen Elbersberg gewinnen. Und wie du schon gesagt hast, es ist eine Mannschaft, die defensiv wirklich stabil ist, die offensiv immer in der Lage ist, Tore zu schießen. Egal wer, wie du schon sagst, da ist immer einer, der das Tor trifft. Und das macht die natürlich auch schwer ausrechenbar. Also ich sehe dem April tatsächlich bei denen gar nicht so skeptisch entgegen, weil ich finde schon, dass Elbersberg von den Mannschaften, die da oben jetzt stehen– Paderborn nehme ich ein bisschen raus– aber den geringsten Druck haben. Also Paderborn will ich ja noch dazuzählen, dass ja auch relativ wenig Druck da ist. Aber Hannover, Schalke, Darmstadt, das sind ja schon Mannschaften, die aufgrund der Konstellationen auch wahrscheinlich eher hoch, Darmstadt vielleicht auch nicht, aber hoch müssen. Und da kann Elbersberg relativ entspannt in diese Spiele gehen. Ein wenig Druck und wozu diese Mannschaft in der Lage ist, das hat sie über den Großteil der Saison gezeigt. Und ich denke schon, wenn die befreit aufspielen können, dass die diese Mannschaften auch immer durchaus mehr als nur ärgern können.
Das ist wirklich ein großes Plus. Das muss ich auch sagen aus der historischen, aus der Historie des SCP gesehen, das ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr großes Plus, wenn du den Druck nicht hast und auch immer nicht als der Oberfavorit angesehen wirst. Das ist schon so, da hast du auch recht. Das könnte sich dann sehr positiv doch für sie aussehen. So habe ich es so nicht gesehen.
Niemand reißt da auch gerne hin. Also ich meine, das ist wirklich komplett wertfrei, der jetzt Freudensprünge macht, wenn er nach Elbersberg fährt. Du weißt einfach, kleine Stadion, ein bisschen nett gemeinte Dorfromantik. Du weißt halt einfach, du kannst, ehrlich gesagt, als so ein bisschen sich selbst als größerer Vereinsehender eigentlich nur verlieren. In allen Bereichen kannst du per se erst mal nur verlieren. Ich kenne ja selber sogenannte Traditionsvereine, haben ja selber schon so einen leichten Anspruch, inklusive der Fans. Und dann sagen sie, ja, dann stehen die halt über uns trotzdem. Ich meine, sollten wir das ja gewinnen und dies und das, ne? Also...
Bei uns immer so, wenn der HSV angereist kam oder wir zum HSV gereist sind, wussten wir immer, das gewinnen wir in 75 Prozent der Fälle, weil die so dermaßen überheblich waren, von der Fan-Tribüne bis auf den Platz. Das war echt immer ein super positiver Effekt, den du da hattest als Underdog.
Aber dann lasst doch auf den ersten FCM gucken. Es ist Platz 18, 23 Punkte, 35 zu 48 Tore, 7 Siege, 2 Unentschieden und 16 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle sieht jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut aus. Da ist man nämlich auf Platz 18. Zuletzt 4 Niederlagen in Folge. Thomas, es ist einfach die ewige Geschichte der mangelnde Torausbeute. Magdeburg gibt die meisten Torschüsse der Liga ab. 418. Das dauert ein bisschen, bis dann der nächste Verein kommt. Macht aber einfach zu wenig draus. Also, again, XG-Tabellen ganz vorsichtig. Aber ich glaube, ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie so eine große Diskrepanz gesehen wie beim FCM. Also laut FodMob müsste Magdeburg auf Platz 7 stehen. 11 Tabellenplätze drüber. Aber man muss eben sagen, 16 Niederlagen sprechen leider auch eine sehr, sehr deutliche Sprache. Du hast ja bist natürlich nah dran. Und man muss ja sagen, ich glaube, es waren ja schon, du hast eben schon mal gesagt, es erinnert eben viel an die Hinrunde, weil zwischendurch sah es ja eigentlich mal besser aus. Also zwischendurch dachte man ja eigentlich, es geht so ein Stück wieder bergauf. Wie ist denn die Stimmung bei dir gerade? Aber was ist denn generell gerade deine Einschätzung?
Oh, wo fangen wir da an? Wo hören wir da auf? Also was jetzt gegen Elbersberg wirklich mal gut war im Vergleich zu den Spielen davor, war endlich mal eine gewisse defensive Stabilität. Die hatten wir ja in den Spielen davor gar nicht. Ganz im Gegenteil, das war ja schon ein Hanebüchen, was wir da hinten in der Abwehr veranstaltet haben. Und ich glaube, diese Serie, so schön die war, zum Ende der Hinrunde mit den 10 Punkten da aus den 4 Spielen, die hat uns so dermaßen Sand in die Augen gestreut, weil dann im Winter der große Fehler gemacht wurde, dass dieser Kader einfach nicht noch verbessert wurde. Wir haben mit Andi Hulti ein Spiel abgegeben, der sicherlich keine Rolle gespielt hat, aber in der Innenverteidigung eben doch fehlt, weil der Heber lange ausfällt, immer wieder verletzt ist, immer wieder Kleinigkeiten hat und nicht spielen kann. Dann hat man da eben einen Richmond Tatchi geholt. Ja, nichts gegen den Tatchi, aber sorry. Das war einfach ein Aktionismus-Kauf für mich. Der war völlig sinnlos, weil er einfach auch eine Position verbessert oder auf einer Position gemacht wurde, wo wir eigentlich in dem Sinne keine Baustelle hatten. Ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass wir vielleicht noch einen Mittelsturm holen und vielleicht noch zwei Verteidiger. Einfach als Ersatz für Joukowsky, weil bei dem müssen wir ja wirklich beten, dass der sich nicht verletzt, weil wenn der ausfällt, dann ist bei uns Eva sowieso da vorne. Also es ist zur Zeit wirklich alles Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Und es ist wirklich, ja, wie gesagt, defensiv ist es einfach nicht gut. Man muss sich vorstellen, wir haben zu Beginn der Rückrunde viel über Dominik Reimer gesprochen. Gerade auch beim Spiel gegen Fürth, wo er bei drei Ecken absolut lächerlich aussieht. Und jetzt macht er gegen in den letzten drei Spielen keinen Fehler und trotzdem kriegt er einen neuen Gegentor. Und das ist einfach Wahnsinn. Und dieser King Elbersberg war jetzt ein bisschen mehr Stabilität drin. Natürlich auch auf Kosten so ein bisschen dieser offensiven Stärke, die man, was heißt Stärke, diese offensiven Spielweise, sagen wir es mal so. Aber ich kann das auch, ich sage ganz ehrlich, ich kann dieses auch, Vincent Wagner hat es ja nach dem Spiel auch gesagt, warum diese Magdeburger da jetzt so da unten stehen. Ja, Tabelle lügt halt nicht. Und wir sind nicht ohne Grund 18. Wir stehen da zu Recht, weil die Abwehr oder die Defensive an sich, ich möchte das gar nicht so auf die Abwehr beschränken, sondern das ist ja auch eine Gesamtmannschaftsleistung. Weil die Defensive an sich einfach nicht gut ist. Wir sind bei Standardsituationen so dermaßen schlecht, sowohl vorne als auch hinten. Und das macht sich eben bemerkbar. Wenn du dann aus dem Spiel heraus nicht viel hinbekommst, dann sieht das eben so aus. Und das mit den Schüssen aufs Tor, das ist ja alles gut und schön. Aber ich glaube, wenn man da mal genauer hinguckt, sieht man, dass wahrscheinlich drei Viertel dieser Schüsse auch von außerhalb des 16. abgegeben wurden. Und das sah dann auch schon viel aus. Wir haben wenig Abschlüsse im Bereich 5-Meter-Raum. Wir haben relativ wenig Abschlüsse im 16. Das ist viel um den 16. herum, weil eben auch so ein bisschen die Idee fehlt, tiefstehende Mannschaften dann eben so zu bespielen, dass man dann auch mal gefährlich in die Räume kommt. Das war vor allem, das kannst du ja bestätigen, denn gegen Bielefeld war das ja auch so. Das war einfach in den letzten Dritteln nicht gut. Das hat sich jetzt gegen Elbersberg in dem Sinne ein bisschen verändert. Ich fand schon, dass wir über Kontersituationen gerade in der ersten Halbzeit gut in die letzte Drittel gekommen sind. Um die 20. Minute herum muss Stukowski einfach das 1-0 machen. Jetzt kommt wieder dieser obligatorische Spruch, wer weiß, wie das Spiel dann läuft. Aber es ist eben nicht passiert. Da braucht man jetzt gar nicht groß drum herum reden. Es ist nicht passiert. Wir haben das Tor nicht gemacht. Am Ende verlierst du dann aufgrund dessen, dass Elbersberg, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, durch immer weiter den Druck aufgebaut hat und uns wirklich hinten reingestützt. Wir sind ja dann ab der 60. Minute kaum noch hinten aus der Abwehr rausgekommen, nur noch lange Bälle geschlagen und kaum noch mal produktiv über Umständensituationen rausgekommen. Dann war das Tor einfach nur eine Frage der Zeit. Das passt einfach zur bisherigen Saison. Ich tue mich da auch schwer, wie Patrick Sandner zu sagen, weil du unten stehst, verlierst du dann so ein Spiel. Nein, wir verlieren so ein Spiel, weil wir auch da in der Situation beim Tor wieder zu weit von den Gegenspielern weg sind. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass man 17. oder 18. oder 16. ist. Es hat einfach damit zu tun, dass man da pennt und nicht nahe genug dran ist. Dann verlierst du so ein Spiel verdient am Ende. Aber Elbersberg ist jetzt auch nicht der Gegner, wo wir unbedingt punkten müssen. Die Spiele kommen dann jetzt hoffentlich noch in den nächsten Wochen. Auch Darmstadt am Freitag wird sehr, sehr schwer. Da brauchen wir, glaube ich, gar nicht drüber reden.
Ich finde es so spannend, weil du es eben schon angesprochen hast. Ich habe das 2-0 gegen Biedelfeld natürlich auch im Stadion verfolgt. Ich fand, man hat da auch einfach dann gemerkt, dass die Stimmung am Anfang, die war klassisch FCM, würde ich erst mal sagen. Aber du hast eben gemerkt, nach dem 1-0, dass das eben wieder nach einem Standard fällt. Da eben auch, auch wenn, ich glaube, Reimann da wirklich diesmal nichts dafür konnte, da fehlte die restliche Zuordnung einfach. Dass du da einfach dann auch im Stadion so langsam, aber sicher auch einfach merkst, dass du zu Hause einfach viel zu wenig Punkte holst. Und es ist halt einfach nicht geil. Also ich glaube, du weißt es natürlich am besten, der FCM ist ein sehr, sehr treues Publikum. Ich meine, wir sind mit dem Auto angereist, da wenn du schon durch über die Dörfer fährst und da überall die FCM-Sticker und Gäste jagen und so siehst, da merkst du schon, was für eine Stahlkraft der Verein noch hat. Aber natürlich ist es eben einfach, wenn du irgendwann merkst, du gehst da alle zwei Wochen hin und alle zwei Wochen kannst du eigentlich irgendwann sagen, ja okay, wir geraten den Rückstandschau. Wir haben nämlich hier in der Folge nach dem 5-4 so lange darüber geredet, was machst du denn als Trainer von beiden Vereinen jetzt mit diesem Ergebnis? Weil auf der einen Seite bei Magdeburg konntest du ja sagen, hey, wir haben in 20 Minuten vier Tore geschossen, voll gut. Gleichzeitig musste man eigentlich sagen, ja, aber warum wird es denn hinten raus noch spannend? So, gleichzeitig konntest du von Führterseite sagen, wir sind einfach komplett Crash-out gegangen für 20 Minuten, haben uns aber irgendwie dann noch eine Position kurzfristig gebracht. Und ich glaube, du hast eben gesagt, Führter die richtigen Lehren aus dem Spiel gezogen. Und man muss ja eigentlich sagen, bei Magdeburg hat man vielleicht das als, also dachte vielleicht, das ist eben ein Dosenöffner, dass man mal wieder fünf Tore erzielt hat, dass man super effizient ja ehrlich gesagt auch in dem Spiel war. Und dann hattest du eben dieses Spiel gegen Bielefeld, glaube ich auch direkt danach, wo man dann einfach sagen musste, das war ja auch vom FCM kein schlechtes Spiel. Also wir haben alle gesagt, eigentlich per se für ein Abstiegskampfspiel war das ja jetzt kein Kick-A-Zone. Aber du konntest beim FCM halt irgendwann sehen, da wurde man auch immer frustrierter vor dem Tor, es wurde immer schneller der Abschluss gesucht, und dann geht es halt leider ganz schnell in so eine Richtung, die du eben halt nicht haben willst. Und das ist dann eben diese Abwehrspirale, die du jetzt eben erreicht hast.
Ja, die Frage ist halt auch für mich, auch nach dem Schalke-Spiel, welche Rolle spielt tatsächlich auch das Trainerteam dann? Ich hoffe, dass das natürlich nur öffentlich passiert und dass man da intern auch ganz anders spricht. Aber was mir hier aufgefallen ist, und das hat mich sehr gestört, dass man nach dem Schalke-Spiel auf der Pressekonferenz und auf Vorbereitung auf das nächste Spiel angesprochen wurde, auf diese 5 Gegentore, die man gegen Schalke bekommen hat. Und sich der Trainer dann hinstellt und sagt, naja, seht doch nicht alles so negativ, wir haben doch auf Schalke 3 Tore geschossen. Wo ich mir dachte, alter, was ist denn jetzt los? Wir können uns doch dafür nichts kaufen, dass du 3 Tore auf Schalke schießt, aber 5er halt bekommst. Das Gleiche jetzt nach dem Spiel gegen, nach dem 1-3 jetzt gegen Karlsruhe, wo er sich dann hinstellt und nach dem Spiel bei Sky sagt, auf die Frage, dann wieder 3 Gegentore, wie wollen sie denn jetzt zukünftig das Defensivverhalten verbessern? Das dritte Tor rechne ich da jetzt einfach mal raus, wo ich mir denke, hä, das war doch ein reguläres Tor während der Spielzeit und das steht doch auf der Anzeigetafel und ist doch auch in der Wertung drin. Also wieso rechne ich denn das denn in meiner Betrachtung dieses Spiels raus? Und da tue ich mich sehr, sehr schwer mit, mit solchen Äußerungen. Und ich hoffe, dass das wirklich nur nach außen getan wird, um da alles ein bisschen runterzuspielen, dass man das intern natürlich ganz, ganz anders anspricht. Und weil so mit der Defensive kann es nicht weitergehen. Du kannst nicht jedes Spiel drei oder vier Tore schießen, um wenigstens einen Punkt zu holen. Das funktioniert nicht. Und der Ansatz, den man jetzt gegen Elbersberg gewählt hat, mal so 10, 15 Meter tiefer zu stehen, Elbersberg, das eben nicht diese Räume zu gehen, dass sie mit Schnelligkeit dann oder mit Geschwindigkeit dann auf den 16er zugehen können, sondern zu sagen, okay, wir stehen tiefer, ihr müsst ein bisschen anders spielen. Das macht mir ein bisschen Hoffnung tatsächlich, dass man erkannt hat, dass es eben mit dieser brutal offensiven Spielweise, wo du den Gegnern 40 Meter vorm Tor richtig böse Räume gibst, wo sie dann reinlaufen können. Ich hoffe, dass das der Weg ist, den man jetzt weitergehen wird. Da muss man aber natürlich auch einen Ticken effizienter vorne werden, weil die Chancen wären natürlich weniger mit so einer Spielweise. Aber ich sage ganz ehrlich, nach den letzten Wochen, ich sehe lieber so ein Spiel wie gegen Elbersberg als noch mal so eine Kicke wie gegen Couto oder Schalke mir angucken zu müssen. Da sage ich ganz ehrlich.
Kevin, du wolltest, glaube ich, auch noch etwas sagen.
Warum hat man Patrick Sander verpflichtet? Ich habe dich das, glaube ich, beim letzten Mal, als wir zusammen waren, schon mal gefragt. Ich verstehe es bis heute nicht. Aber ich finde das total krass, das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden. Verein mit dem Umfeld, mit der Vita und dem Aufschwung der letzten Jahre, dass die keinen anderen Staff oder Trainer finden, so wie du es gerade gesagt hast, die auch ganz anders auftreten nach außen und nicht so als dieses gebückte Ding, doch war so schlecht, war es ja gar nicht. Mein Gott, besser geht es halt nicht bei uns. Das finde ich total schwierig. Ich finde auch, es wird dem Verein nicht gerecht. Das finde ich für die Fans total schade. Ich bin da, weiß Gott, nicht so nah dran, aber ich weiß nicht, mir tut das auch ein bisschen weh, das zu sehen, wie die Entwicklung da ist. Vor allem, wenn man den Fußball der letzten Jahre sieht vom FCM. Es ist schon bitter. Und wenn man sieht, der letzte Heimsieg, 29. November, habe ich gerade noch mal geguckt. Ich habe echt lange scrollen müssen. Alter Schwede.
Die Mannschaft hat sich auf jeden Fall schon in die Geschichtsbücher des Vereins eingetragen. Neun Heimwiederlehrer hat man noch nie.
Das ist krass und das war eine Bastion mal. Ich weiß noch, als wir in der 3. Liga zu euch gefahren sind, hatten wir jedes Mal die Buchse voll. Da haben wir immer gedacht, boah, in Magdeburg willst du nicht spielen.
Aber das ist schon seit…
Ich weiß, das ist lange her.
Also, letzte Saison war zu Hause auch schon katastrophal. Wir waren, glaube ich, auch 18er an der Heimtabelle. Man muss sich mal vorstellen, 18er und dann trotzdem Fünfte gewonnen am Ende. Das sagt doch viel über die Liga letztes Jahr. Aber auch das Jahr davor. Also, das ist so, seit zwei, drei Jahren ist das zu Hause… Katastrophe, ja. Also, wie gesagt, diese Saison die Krönung. Also, so schlecht waren wir nicht mal in diesem rotten, schlechten Jahr, 10, 11, wo wir nur drin geblieben sind wegen der Regionalliga-Reform damals. Und seitdem, selbst diese Mannschaft, hat es geschafft, nur achtmal zu Hause zu verlieren. Die Gruppe hat es jetzt echt geschafft, wahrscheinlich eine Ewigkeit aufzustellen.
Also, bei euch bin ich wirklich gespannt auf das nächste Programm, so was zu kommen, weil ihr habt so Top-Mannschaft-Gegner, dann so Konkurrent, dann wieder Top-Mann, also so ein Wechsel. Ich glaube, es könnte euch sogar zu Gute kommen, weil auch die Mannschaften oben immer wieder mal straucheln. Aber ihr werdet auch so ein paar Teams haben, die vielleicht– Eva hat es vorhin schon woanders gesagt– die dann vielleicht schon durch sind. Man denkt immer so, das ist dann einfacher. Manchmal ist das ja auch weit gefehlt.
Klassische 6-6 oder so.
Also zum Beispiel so Heimspiel gegen Hertha. Schönen Grüß an Marc. Aber mal weghören, Marc. Aber das wäre doch prädestiniert zum Beispiel, um da schon mal drei Punkte einzupreisen.
Ja, das ist natürlich immer die Gefahr. Spiel in ein paar Lagerbunden geht bestimmt auch was. Wir haben an den letzten beiden Spielen Kaiserslautern und Hertha. Von daher bin ich die zwei Teams, die dann auf jeden Fall durch sind. Und das kann gut sein, das kann aber natürlich auch richtig schlecht sein. Weil dann eben für die geht es um nichts mehr. Und für die eine Mannschaft geht es um alles. Das ist immer so ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Kleine Info noch für die, die es vielleicht nicht auf dem Schirm haben. Es folgt jetzt das Heimspiel gegen Darmstadt. Das wird allerdings ohne einen Teil der Fans stattfinden. Da gab es einen Teilausschluss von der– Lass es mich gerade kon- Ja, schwierig. So, nochmal von vorne anfangen, den Satz. Lass es mich korrekt wiedergeben. Die Blöcke 3 bis 6 der Nordtribüne, die werden gesperrt werden. Das ist eben ein Ergebnis bzw. die Sanktion nach den gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen gegen Dynamo Dresden. Ich bin sicher, die Videos haben viele von euch gesehen. Ich glaube, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht so ins Detail geben. Insgesamt noch eine Geldstrafe von 186.600 Euro. Auch das, was den Verein wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig top treffen wird in der aktuellen Situation. Das ist eben das Spiel auf weitere Bewehrungen ausgesetzt. Falls es jetzt eben im Spiel darauf zur Ausschreitung kommen sollte, kann es eben auch sein, dass man im Endspurt weiterhin auf seine Fans verzichtet. Der FCM hat dem übrigens ohne Erwiderung zugestimmt. Auch das, wir haben es gerade darüber diskutiert, Heimstärke ist eh nicht. Haufe, jetzt mal vorsichtig formuliert.
Ja, Gott, jetzt kriege ich Schlag irgendwo im MWF.
Ja, ich meine, das ist dann natürlich auch immer ein bisschen Spekulation, aber ja, also ich kann nur sagen, Thomas, ich fühle da natürlich sehr mit dir mit im Abstiegskampf, aber ich habe auch einfach entschieden, ich mache gar keine Prognosen mehr. Also ich ärgere mich seit drei Wochen schwarz, hätten wir dieses Spiel gegen Fürth einfach gewonnen, dann wäre es glaube ich alles ein bisschen entspannter. Aber ich kenne das, hier spricht man auch seit, nach den knappen Niederlagen gegen Hannover und Schalke, ist es eben auch dieses so, naja, eigentlich haben wir ja gar nicht so schlecht gespielt. Und Schalke gewinnt nur, weil unser Torhüter da schlecht steht gegen Hannover, das ist ein Elfmeter, und eigentlich schießen wir da ja auch zwei Mal Tore, die werden aber auch beide Male aberkannt. Und ich merke das als Fan auch selber, dass du dich in so Szenarien verfängst und immer denkst, ah ja, da, und du fängst halt an zu rechnen, und das ist immer ganz schlecht. Den Tabellenrechner, den schmeiß ich gar nicht erst an, gerade nicht in dieser Liga, wo alles irgendwie noch drin ist. Aber du rechnest irgendwie alles durch und fängst an, wie wütend zu werden, weil gegnerische Vereine irgendwie nicht ihren Job machen. Und du denkst, ja, gegen uns hätten sie das ja auch mal machen können. Das ist einfach super nervig und ich weiß das noch von unserem Abstiegsjahr vor ein paar Jahren. Du hast immer kein Bock mehr und du wirst es sicherlich dann auch noch jede Woche drüber zu reden. Du denkst ja auch immer so, ja, selben Song nochmal.
Ihr kennt es ja auch aus der Hinrunde, also von daher.
Ja, es geht einfach immer weiter.
Aber wenn es dann wie eine Hinrunde gleichmäßig verläuft, dann reicht es ja am Ende.
Hm, glaube ich nicht. Also ich denke schon, wir haben ja in den letzten vier Spielen zehn Punkte gewonnen. Ich glaube, das wird diesmal nicht reichen, weil die da unten einfach auch inzwischen konstanter Punkte. Guckt ihr die Resten an, die spielen eine überragende Rückrunde für ihre Verhältnisse. Und das führt jetzt erkannt, Mensch, wenn wir nur zwei, drei Spiele gewinnen, haben wir auch eine Chance, da unten rauszukommen. Also diese zehn Punkte, die werden nicht reichen. Also ich denke schon, dass du am Ende fünf, sechsunddreißig, siebenunddreißig, vielleicht sogar achtunddreißig Punkte brauchst, um sicher drin zu bleiben. Und also mal gucken.
Ja, das Problem ist einfach…
Ich habe die Rechnung aufgemacht für uns, du brauchst minimum noch vier Siege. Mir fehlt gerade tatsächlich so ein bisschen der Glaube gegen, wen wir die holen sollen.
Ich kann dir die nennen, aber das springt die Sendung.
Ja, ich glaube, das ganz große Problem, was wir da haben…
Wie Franko Münzt immer an.
Das finde ich einen super Plan. Aus ganz uneigenden Zingründen. Nee, was natürlich ein wirklich spannendes Thema unironisch noch sein wird, ist das Torverhältnis. Also wir haben Magdeburg mit minus 13, Braunschalke mit minus 15, Führer mit minus 19. So, führt weiterhin schlechteste Defensive der Liga. Brauchen wir nicht lange darüber reden. Aber Magdeburg folgt dann eben darauf. Also das ist eben das Ding. Und das wird, glaube ich… Also, ich sage auch mal so, dir werden die Punkte nicht nur reichen. Es wird wirklich zum Ende hin ganz, ganz viel darauf ankommen, wie du gewinnst oder verlierst du die Spiele eben. Weil dafür ist das unten alles viel zu nah beieinander. Und du willst nicht am letzten Spieltag so einen… Einfach nur darauf gucken, ah, okay, gewinnt die Mannschaft jetzt 3-1 oder 4-1? So, ne? Was brauchen wir? Wie viele Tore brauchen wir? Wie viele Tore müssen die anderen kassieren? Das willst du ja am letzten Spieltag auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Weil dann ist dann… Also, ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendein Spieler ablegen kann. Also dann rechnest du ja nur noch. Also dann… Fans rechnen nur, verantwortlich rechnen nur. Das ist das Schlechteste, was dir hinten raus, ehrlich gesagt, passieren kann. Ähm, von daher… Ja, bin ich mal gespannt. Ich meine, du siehst jetzt bei Bielefeld, die stehen eigentlich nur so gut da, weil sie noch ein positives Torverhältnis haben, ne? Also, da wäre es schon ein paar Mal weiter unten in der Tabelle gewesen, dann hätte man eben nicht zu Anfang der Saison und zum Teil da hohe Siege eingefahren. Und das ist eben das Problem, Thomas, was du eben auch schon mal so ein bisschen angesprochen hast, ist ja schön und gut, dass man da drei Tore schießt und da fünf Tore schießt. Aber wenn du gleichzeitig halt auch immer vier oder fünf kassierst, ist die Rechnung halt ganz, ganz schnell weg. Und dann ist auch vollkommen egal, wie das eine Tor gefallen ist und bla. Das ist dann egal. Und wenn du das ist, ich mache auch einen Phrasenschwein auf, du musst die Tore vorne machen. Und das Ding ist ja wirklich, die Torschüsse hast du ja. Also du kommst ja in die Position, auch Torschüsse zu machen. Aber alleine davon, ich glaube, irgendwie hat irgendwie seine 45 XG oder so, also zehn Tore mehr hätte man schon mal schießen sollen, was trotzdem gemessen an der Menge der Torschüsse, die du abgibst, ja auch irgendwie nicht so ganz aufgeht. Also das ist eben das große Problem, was sich eben durchzieht, die defensivste Stabilität, die fehlt und gleichzeitig eben offensiv. Wir sind gespannt. Wie gesagt, zu Hause gegen Darmstadt, auswärts in Münster sind die nächsten Partien. Bevor wir auf unser letztes Spiel kommen, habe ich noch Ankündigungen mitgebracht, beziehungsweise erstmal so eine kleine Feedback-Schleife, das hatten wir hier noch nicht so richtig, aber ich wollte einmal Danke sagen, auch wenn es vier Wochen näher ist, für das Feedback zur letzten Folge, natürlich im Forum, unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, aber eben auch bei YouTube. Und da ganz besonders eben auch Danke an die Schalke-Fans. Ich weiß, manchen von euch hat das vielleicht nicht so gut gefallen. Ich glaube, wir hatten im Kern trotzdem richtige Punkte, aber ihr habt oder ein paar User haben auf jeden Fall auch richtige Punkte gemacht, die wir so eben nicht erwähnt haben und nicht auf dem Schirm hatten. Und Kritik ist eigentlich immer gerne willkommen, vor allem, wenn es konstruktive Kritik ist, weil damit kann ich oder können wir als All-Star-Team tatsächlich am besten was mit anfangen, als wenn ihr einfach nur drunter schreibt, ja, fand ich scheiße. Also, dann ist okay, könnt ihr machen, aber damit kann ich tatsächlich sehr wenig mit anfangen. Und tatsächlich auch nochmal der Hinweis, wenn es euch so sehr triggert, dass ich gendersensible Sprache benutze, tut es mir leid, aber ich werde deshalb damit nicht aufhören. Da müsst ihr dann entweder mit klarkommen oder euch tatsächlich einfach dann einen anderen Podcast suchen, so leid es mir tut. Aber viele von euch, die sind weiterhin dabei und sind auch Unterstützerinnen, Supporterinnen und Supporterinnen, denn ihr wisst es, der Werbe, der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsor- und frei, nicht der Werbefunk. Das wäre was anderes. Vielen Dank, dass ihr viele von euch eben schon bereits Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter seid. Wenn ihr das werden wollt, guckt gerne mal in den Shownotes. Wenn es ein Euro im Monat ist, freuen wir uns darüber. Weil ihr finanziert damit eben nicht nur Max, sondern eben auch unsere Gastinnen und eben Marc und mich als Moderatorin. Und ihr finanziert die Menge an Sendungen, die eben rauskommt. Gestern, also am Sonntag, ist die Folge zu den Qualispielen der Frauen erschienen. Die haben ja insgesamt neun Tore geschossen. Heute ist zur Bundesliga-Sendung der Männer eine Folge entschieden. Da habe ich mich erfolgreich von Martin Raffelt geratespaitet. Ich sehe Bielefeld in der Folgenbeschreibung. Ich denke mir so, was hat Dortmund jetzt gerade mit Bielefeld zu tun und warum mussten sie auf einem Acker spielen? Letzte Woche ist die Ligatour Europa erschienen. Eventuell erscheint diese Woche noch ein Schwerpunkt. Das ist aber noch nicht so ganz klar, da einfach die Augen und Ohren offen halten. Und sonst kann ich schon mal sagen, nächste Folge erscheint in zwei Wochen. Dann werden wir wahrscheinlich wieder die Länderspielpause für drei Wochen nutzen, weil es einfach mehr Sinn ergibt, dann doch eigentlich immer zwei Spieltage abzuwarten. Gerade jetzt zum Saison-Endspurt hin, weil sonst hört die hier tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch zum Ende hin immer die gleiche Leier. Und das möchte wirklich niemand. So, wir kommen auf unser letztes Spiel. Und das war zwischen Münster und Hertha BSC. Und ich sage schon mal, die Vereine oder die Tore, die da gefallen sind, die waren gar nicht mal der größte Star dieses Spiels, sondern ein Kabel. Dazu gleich mehr. Das zweite Spiel in Folge. Auch das nach den geplatzten Ausstiegsträumen gewinnt Hertha BSC knapp mit 2 zu 1. Dabei sorgt eben vor allem ein Stromkabel für viel Aufmerksamkeit. Kurz vor der Pause vor Cooles Cuisance. Nach VR-Prüfung gibt es Elfmeter. Den verwandelt Reese auch. Allerdings wird diese Entscheidung von Videoschiedsrichterin Katrin Rafalski getroffen, denn der Bildschirm in Münster bleibt schwarz. Schiedsrichter Bickel sieht nichts und sagt dann eben auch durch meine Kollegin Katrin Rafalski, hat eben diesen Kontakt gesehen. Grund dafür ist, dass Mitglieder der Fans in Münster sich Zutritt zum Innenraum verschafft haben und den Stecker gezogen haben, das mit dem Spruchband, dem VR, den Stecker ziehen, direkt bestätigt haben. Es ist ein super Bild, wenn da oben noch drüber steht auf der Tribüne. Ich glaube, gemeinsam digitale Lösungen verwicklichen. Das waren 10 von 10 Text-Wildschirre. Das ist tatsächlich ein Bild der Saison, könnte man tatsächlich sagen. Münster und der DFB ermitteln. Man muss dazu sagen, im Münster-Stadion wird umgebaut. Ihr werdet das alle mitbekommen haben. Daher befindet sich die Fanszene von Preuß Münster gerade im ehemaligen Gäste-Blog und so eben auch näher dran an diesem TV-Bildschirm. Und ja, trotzdem muss ich auch sagen, sah tatsächlich sehr witzig aus. Und ich war tatsächlich sehr verwirrt, dass man so einfach wirklich dieses komplette Konstrukt einmal ausschalten kann, indem man einfach einen Stecker zieht und man ihn tatsächlich einfach nicht wieder reinstecken kann. Und dann funktioniert es wieder. Also es war nicht, ja, doch, durch, ich glaube, jeder ITler dachte da auch nur so, naja, wir können noch nicht mal sagen, have you tried turning the gate off? Notfallmanagement.
Notfallmanagement, so wichtig.
Das hat mich auf jeden Fall abgeholt. Aber zurück zum Spiel. Münster kann durch Heuer kurz noch wieder ein Fünf ausgleichen. Die Comeback-Münsterranne schlagen da nochmal kurz zu. Das letzte Wort, das hat dann allerdings Martin Winkler, der nach einem Konter in der dritten Minute der Nachspielzeit zum 2-1 vollendet. Wir schauen zuerst auf Preußen Münster. Die stehen momentan auf Platz 14, 26 Punkte, 30 zu 38 Tore, 6 Siege, 8 Unentschieden, 11 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle, da ist man im Gegensatz zur letzten Sendung ein bisschen nach oben geklettert. Platz 14 ist es, ein Sieg, ein Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Es gab einen wichtigen Sieg gegen Braunschweig letzte Woche. Davor eine knappe Niederlage gegen Kaiserslautern und ein Unentschieden gegen Bochum. Es ist Thomas die Mannschaft, die die zweitmeisten Punkte nach Rückstand holt. 14 sind es bisher, 19 Mal musste man bisher einen Rückstand hinnehmen. Drei Siege, fünf Unentschieden und elf Niederlagen. Das ist ja eigentlich schon mal eine ganz gute Quote. Allerdings muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen, dafür gerät man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu oft in Rückstand. Was glaubst du denn? Also man hat ja zwischendurch eigentlich das Gefühl, Preußen ist eigentlich ganz gut dabei. Die werden mit dem Abstieg vielleicht eher nichts zu tun haben. Wir wissen alle, unter Ende hat man gut in Fußball gespielt. Aber jetzt so zuletzt, es sah schon noch mal schlechter aus, aber man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, man schlägt sich häufig einfach mit eigenen Waffen und mit Unaufmerksamkeiten. Siehst du das auch so?
Ja, ein schönes Beispiel ist der Strafstoß zum 0 zu 1. Das zieht sich ja dann auch. Die Frage ist immer, ist es dann nur Pech, wie man ja gerne mal sagt, dass die unten stehenden Mannschaften Pech haben, oder ist es dann eben doch in dem Fall dann einfach fehlende Qualität, die dann eben dafür sorgt, dass man in solchen Zweikämpfen zu spät da ist oder sich halt einfach auch ein bisschen dämlich anstellt in solchen Situationen. Von daher schwierig, aber ich glaube Münster ist das, also da wird jetzt keiner unruhig, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Denen war von Anfang an klar, es geht nur gegen den Abstieg. Die sind in der Rolle, in der sie in meinen Augen von Saisonbeginn auch sich gesehen haben, denke ich mal. Ich glaube nicht, da hatte keiner Höhenflüge und hat gesagt, wir werden die Tabelle 8er oder so. Ich glaube, die Träume hatte man in Münster nicht. Von daher denke ich schon, die sind im Soll. Die sind da, wo sie stehen sollen, stehen immer noch über dem Strich. Ich habe schon gesagt, dass die Formtabelle ist okay für eine Mannschaft von da unten. Die haben das wichtige Spiel gegen Braunschweig gewonnen. Also diese direkten Duellen, die holen sie. Hertha ist ja nun, auch wenn die jetzt so diesen Aufstiegskampf für sich beendet haben, aber Hertha ist ja nun auch trotzdem keine Laufkundschaft. Ist ja trotzdem eine starke Mannschaft. Und die haben sie so lange, die haben sie wirklich gut bespielt. Am Ende dann in der Nachspielzeit das 1 zu 2 kassiert. Also ich glaube, Münster muss sich weniger Sorgen machen als der eine oder andere Verein unten.
Kevin, wie schaust du auf die Münsteraner?
Erst einen Sieg in der Rückrunde und dann auch mal in Braunschweig. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so, das ist dann ein Achtungserfolg. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt gerade schwierig für mich, das Argument rauszuholen, aber es ist halt auch in Braunschweig. Ja, das war jetzt irgendwie nicht so klug, aber gut.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, was?
Ja, du hast vorhin gesagt, wir bauen immer solche Mannschaften auf. Wir machen das in Badawan auch gern. Ja, weiß ich nicht, also das ist mir zu wenig. Ein paar Unentschieden, 1-1 dabei. Jetzt verlierst du gegen die Hertha zu Hause, für die angeblich alles schon gelaufen war. Da können wir gleich noch drüber sprechen, ob die jetzt ins Geheimtuch wieder hoffen. Ich bin da nicht so sicher. Die müssen jetzt nach Dresden, dann gegen Magdeburg. Das sind zwei Spiele. Dann nach Kiel, Altersschede.
Guck mal weiter.
Und dann nach Fürth, ach du liebe Güte. Also eigentlich hat Münster jetzt ein Endprogramm. Also die müssen jetzt vorlegen. Ich glaube, die sind nicht so entspannt. Letzte Saison haben die auch eine ziemliche Kurzschlussreaktion auf dem Trainerposten irgendwann mal getätigt.
Aber alles richtig gemacht.
Ja gut, das sehe ich tatsächlich, glaube ich nicht. Weil damit musst du vor der Saison gerechnet haben. Dafür war Alex Ende von Anfang an natürlich ein gewisses Risiko als Trainer eben auch. Aber jetzt nochmal, sie spielen entweder gegen direkte Abstiegskonkurrenten oder nur noch gegen Mannschaften von oben. Also Dresden, Magdeburg, Kiel führt, Schalke, Bielefeld, Hannover, Darmstadt, Helversberg.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich versuche mal, meine persönlichen Strömungen auszublenden. Und da fehlt mir dann trotzdem die Fantasie, wie Münster, also wie Münster, also Münster ist für mich eine der Kandidaten noch und auf die letzten drei Plätze rutschen wird. Weil Thomas, so was gesagt, Dresden glaube ich nicht, dass sie da was holen. Ich würde, sie sind sehr stark unterwegs in dieser Rekunde.
Sehr stabil, ja.
So jetzt zu Hause gegen euch, okay. Aber da habe ich eher gedacht, da könntet ihr vielleicht was landen und dann weiß ich nicht. Also ich sehe gerade nicht diesen Push, den Münster irgendwo herholt. Ich weiß nicht. Also klar kann man jetzt sagen, den hat natürlich Magdeburg auch nicht. So, aber ich habe bei Münster gerade kein Gefühl und das ist immer so schlechter als ein Gefühl zu haben, finde ich. Ich kann das nicht ganz begründen. Ich finde die Spiele zu ineffektiv, zu viel Graue.
Ja, ich glaube einfach so ein bisschen das, was…
Sorry, da fehlen die Adjektive.
Ne, alles gut. Das, was zu Beginn der Saison eben zum Teil sehr, sehr gut funktioniert hat, das geht halt jetzt zum Teil nicht mehr auf. Gleichzeitig bist du super abhängig von jemandem, wie meiner Meinung nach Battista Meyer. Also, der bringt seine Qualität mit, aber ich habe schon so das Gefühl, dass also, ob er trifft, ob er nicht trifft, das kann schon mal so ein Spiel entscheiden. Für super torell entscheidende Spiele, ich weiß, das ist der Hot Take des Tages.
Wir überschlagen uns heute hier.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich damit meine, das ist schon jemand, der kann eben mit seiner individuellen Qualität viel machen. Ich bin auch weiterhin der Meinung, er macht natürlich auch viel. Aber klar ist es ein gutes Zeichen, dass du als Mannschaft nie aufgibst und eben noch 14 Punkte nach Rückstand geholt hast. Aber gleichzeitig, ich sag's gerne nochmal, 19 Rückstände. Das heißt nicht, dass das nicht nach Spielen geht, sondern wirklich, wie oft du in einem Spiel in Rückstand geraten bist. Dann sind 11 Niederlagen halt auch immer noch relativ viel. Im Vergleich dazu hat Darmstadt 15 Punkte aus 10 Rückständen geholt. Du siehst dann natürlich auch, ist natürlich fies der Vergleich. Aber ich sehe es immer wieder bei Münster-Fans in meiner Timeline, die einfach sagen, es ist eigentlich jede Woche das Gleiche. Du denkst eben, es ist jetzt gar nicht, dass wir klar unterlegen sind in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Du siehst jetzt irgendwie nicht, das und das ist nicht Zweitligatauglich, aber wie bei so vielen Mannschaften gerade da unten drin, dir fehlt eben die Durchschlagskraft. Und das ist einfach, also ich glaube tatsächlich aus mehreren Gründen einfach auch, wann dieses Spiel stattfindet, ist das Derby gegen Bielefeld für beide Mannschaften, ist da richtig, richtig viel drin. Weil das kann, alleine in der Position, in der Tabelle, kann das richtig viel, also kann das vielleicht sogar entscheidende drei Punkte sein hinten raus. Natürlich dann total entspannt, dass es so stattfindet. Aber ja, also man muss halt sagen, Hertha war ja durchaus auch schlagbar in diesem Spiel. Also Hertha hatte ein typisches Hertha-Spiel zuletzt. Ich meine, die haben jetzt ein Spiel zuvor gewonnen, ja in Nürnberg, wenn ich mich an sich alles täusche, ja. Und jetzt eben das Spiel, es ist, ja, du merkst bei denen, wir reden gleich noch über den, da sind irgendwie 80 andere Probleme auch immer noch am Start. Und du weißt, da scheint auch einfach trotzdem auf dem Feld so ein bisschen die Luft raus. Ja, aber Münster, also ich glaube weiterhin für viele Vereine da unten drin sind Braunschweig und Kiel zwei Punkte. Einfach weil Braunschweig, ja, die sind erprobt im Abstiegskampf. Aber jedes Jahr da wieder drin zu stecken, das muss irgendwann, also ich habe das Gefühl, da kann es halt auch jetzt irgendwann mal knallen. So richtig nochmal, gerade auch da, weil das Derby ansteht. Und Kiel haben wir eben auch in Lengen drüber gesprochen. Also das kann für Vereine wie Münster, weil es können eben nicht fünf Vereine absteigen. Das ist einfach so zwei Steine. Auch nochmal Hot Take, aber zwei Vereine steigen ab, eine geht in die Relegation. Wenn man gerade in die 3. Liga guckt, weiß man da auch nicht, wie man da am wenigsten haben will, ehrlich gesagt. So geht es mir auf jeden Fall. Ich wollte eigentlich nicht nach Ferl, um da Relegation zu spielen. Ja, also weiß ich nicht. Es ist, ich würde sie noch nicht komplett abschreiben, sowieso nicht von der Tabellensituation, aber ich sehe auf jeden Fall deine Punkte, Kevin. Aber ich kann halt auch nicht so, ich sehe halt nicht, wie wir haben über Magdeburg über defensive Instabilität gesprochen. Wir haben bei Führer darüber gesprochen, dass sie das wieder geschafft haben. Bei Münster sehe ich halt nicht so das eine ganz große Problem, wo man wirklich direkt sagen kann, okay, das gehen wir jetzt einfach mal an. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Schwierigkeit, weil sie machen ja immer noch viel richtig.
Ich kann die total schwer greifen, ich weiß auch nicht. Also sie stehen ja eigentlich sogar auf Platz 14 richtig, weil Heim- und Auswärtstabelle sind sie 14. Insofern wird da ein Argument, dass sie da vielleicht bleiben. Übrigens krass, was Nürnberg nur acht Auswärtspunkte wollte. Egal, anderes Thema. Aber ich kann Münster einfach nicht fassen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach so nicht bewandert genug bei dem Club. Ich habe bei denen irgendwie keine so richtige Meinung. Mir fehlte gerade so die springende Fantasie, dass sie jetzt die nächsten vier Spiele gewinnen könnten. Definitiv vom Potenzial her. Und dann durchwehren, dass sie die auch wirklich gewinnen. Die Historie dieser 2. Liga lässt mich daran zweifeln, dass eine Mannschaft vier Spiele in Folge unten im Tabellenkeller gewinnen wird gegen direkte Konkurrenten. Und dann kommen ja noch die Mannschaften oben. Also das spricht für mich. Ich weiß nicht warum. Klar, man könnte jetzt sagen, Kevin ist ja Quatsch, weil die können ja jetzt mit den nächsten vier Spielen alles klar machen. Dann können sie auch gegen die oben verlieren. Ich sage, sie gewinnen aber nicht alle vier gegen diese Mannschaften unten und kriegen dann noch auf den Deckel von denen, die oben stehen. Und dann haben sie das schlechteste Momentum hinten raus. Ach, egal.
Ich rede mir um Kopf und Kran. Ich sage gerne nochmal, ich prognose, ich lasse es einfach. Ich lasse es einfach bleiben. Es ist für mich, wenn ich so ein bisschen meine Kontonance behalten will, dann reg ich mich auch weniger auf, wenn es hinterher geht. Ich glaube, ich bin das Quatsch.
Ich sage mal, so viert wurde ich ja auch schon tot geredet.
Wie gesagt, bei Dresden habe ich auch schon dreimal gesagt, also die haben sich ja verbessert, aber ich sehe es nicht langfristig. Ja, schauen wir mal.
Das muss jetzt aber auch erstmal weiter punkten. Das kann ja jetzt auch so ein schöner März gewesen sein. Und dann ist es jetzt wieder...
Ich habe ja per se weniger, aber gut.
Aber Münster hat es eben jetzt die nächsten vier Wochen in der Hand. Also das ist eben...
Danke.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Entschuldigung, Thomas.
Alles gut. Aber Münster hat es jetzt gegen direkte Konkurrenz in der Hand.
Die müssen jetzt direkt zünden, ja.
Und ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch einfacher, als diese Spiele hinten rauszuhaben. Ich glaube schon, dass bei den vermeintlichen Aufstiegskandidaten, die da am Ende kommen, geht ja dann auch das Denken los. Ich kann mich erinnern, Darmstadt damals, als sie vor drei Jahren aufgestiegen sind. Die haben auch drei Spiele gebraucht, um den Aufstieg dann fix zu machen. Da haben sich auch Schüler gefragt, wird das noch was? Und dann haben sie am vorletzten Spiel nach gegen uns dann den Aufstieg klargemacht. Aber die hatten dann auch drei Spiele davor, wo sie es hätten klar machen können und es einfach nicht geschafft haben. Ich glaube, ich werde vorsichtig zu sagen, wenn dann hinten raus die Schwerenbrunnen kommen, auch die müssen dann erst mal noch über diese Ziellinie gehen.
Das Münster-Letzte-Sorte.
Schauen wir mal. Okay.
Letzte-Sorte Münster am Ende, das ist vermutlich leichtere Programm.
Also ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich würde das Wort leicht einfach in dieser Liga nicht mehr in den Mund nehmen. Das ist wirklich… Das ist einfach… also ich glaube, wie gesagt, bis auf gefühlt vier Vereine wird da am Ende, das wird, weiß ich nicht, Mord und Totschlag ebenso ungefähr. Ja, das ist schon eine große Serie.
Jens hat als Tabellen-17. der letzte Saison am 32. Spieltag beim Tabellen-4. übrigens 5 zu 0 gewonnen. Das wollte ich nur mal erwähnen.
Ich erinnere mich.
Ja, und also das ist halt nicht unmöglich.
Ja, echt. Ja, und am letzten Spieltag ging Ulm, ne? 2-2.
Ja, es ist, es bleibt ein großes Fragezeichen. Aber ja, wo man sagen könnte, das Fragezeichen da ist eigentlich weg, ist bei Hertha BSC. Platz 6 ist es gerade, 40 Punkte. 36 zu 30 Tore, 11 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 7 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle ist man Platz 10, 2 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Ja, nach der 5 zu 2 Niederlage ging Paderborn und Stefan Leitel die Aufstiegspläne ad acta gelegt. Gleichzeitig weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt für euch alle da draußen gut oder schlecht war, dass Marc direkt nach diesem Spiel hätte aufnehmen müssen. Ich glaube sogar mit dir, Kevin, vielleicht gut, dass es nicht der Welt entblickt habe. Ich glaube für die allgemeine gute Stimmung in dieser Gruppe war es besser, dass es diese Folge nicht gab. Heute hat der Körper von Marc da vorher einmal gesagt, wir lassen das lieber. Der hat doch schon was geahnt, was der Rest noch nicht so wusste. Aber Stefan Leithl hat eben selber gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht einfach etwas fürs Vierenraum geworfen hat, sondern Stefan Leithl hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, der Ausstieg ist bei uns nicht mehr drin. Es wurden, ich glaube, 1800 Abgesänger auf die alte Dame geschrieben. Weil man eben auch gesagt hat, du kannst sicherlich gegen Paderborn verlieren, aber die Art und Weise, wie man eben verloren hat, die waren ein bisschen zu viel. Davor hatte man eben auch eine Niederlage einstecken müssen. Man hat jetzt zwei Siege geholt per se, wenn man auf die Tabelle guckt. Klar sind es nur acht Punkte, aber ich glaube, man muss gleichzeitig sagen, dafür ist es da oben zu eng. Und da muss ja mindestens drei Teams hinter dich lassen. Das wird schon ehrlich gesagt eine Nummer. Jetzt hat man eben unter anderem in Münster gewonnen. Ich habe eben schon mal gesagt, ich hatte trotzdem ein bisschen das Gefühl, die Luft ist so ein bisschen raus. Also du merkst auch bei Lytle, der hat einiges Systemumstände, bzw. keine Systemumstellung gemacht, sondern du siehst so ein bisschen, da werden einigen Spieler schon deutliche Messages geschickt, sage ich mal vorsichtig. So nach dem Motto, okay, jetzt ist sowieso egal, dann können wir dich da auch wieder hinpacken und du kommst da raus. Das siehst du, glaube ich, schon. Also vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Also auch das zeigt eben überhaupt, dann ist es jetzt halt so. Kevin, vielleicht erst einmal kurz allgemein. Wir haben, ich glaube, in der Gruppe, generell auch vor der Saison, wir haben sehr kontrovers immer darüber diskutiert, was machen wir denn mit Hertha BSC? Weil der Verein ja selber sehr konfrontativ eben in diese Saison gegangen ist und offensiv gesagt hat, wir wollen aufsteigen. So, wir wissen alle, was finanziell bei der Hertha hintersteht, etc. Woran liegt es denn deiner Meinung nach jetzt, dass man eben schon einige, insgesamt glaube ich 11 Spieltage vor Schluss gesagt hat? Ja, also Aufstieg, 1. Liga ohne uns nächste Saison.
Also erstmal ist das ein richtiges Armutszeugnis für so ein Verein. Das hätte ich gerne auch mag, so gesagt, ohne jetzt gehässig sein zu wollen, aber das ist wirklich ein Armutszeugnis diese Saison, was die abgeliefert haben. Für das, was die sich vorgenommen haben, dass sie angeblich den idealen Trainer gefunden haben, der den Kader ja irgendwie auch mit zusammengestellt hat. Jetzt kann man immer draufhören und sagen, ja, das ist schlecht, wenn man so einen Star in der Mannschaft hat, der eigentlich schon längst woanders hätte spielen müssen. Rese meine ich natürlich zum Beispiel. Wäre es vielleicht doch besser gewesen, wenn man viele Spieler hat, die auf Augenhöhe agieren. Vielleicht. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Dazu bin ich nicht nahe genug an diesem Verein dran. Du hast zum Glück die Tipps nicht rausgeholt vor der Saison. Ich glaube, ich habe Hertha auf eins getippt, kann das sein. Aber auch nur zum ersten Mal seit langer Zeit, dass ich mal Experten-Tipps gemacht habe. Also mitgegangen bin. Ich glaube, ich habe Hertha, Schalke und Haufe auf die ersten drei Plätze getippt.
Einer von drei bist du schon mal gut.
Siehst du? Mit dem SCP habe ich auf Platz 7 getippt. Nachdem ich den jahrelang immer auf die ersten drei getippt habe, dachte ich mir, egal, woran liegt es bei der Hertha? Ich finde, das, was die gerade spielen, was du so beschrieben hast, die Luft ist raus, habe ich schon immer wieder in dieser Sorge gehabt, wo ich mir dachte, jetzt haben die gerade ein Spiel gewonnen oder zwei Spiele auch mal. Du hast das Gefühl, jetzt könnte ja diese berühmte Serie starten und dann hast du so wieder ein, zwei Spiele danach gehabt, wo auch Marc dann ja gesagt hat oder auch geschrieben hat bei uns in der WhatsApp-Gruppe. Krass eklatant, gar keine Ambition offenbar, dieses Spiel. Mal so diese berühmten Prozent auf die 100 draufzulegen und so eine Mannschaft niederzuspielen, auch einfach gegen die man da geht. Also auch das, Thomas, du hast vorhin gesagt, 2. Liga anzunehmen einfach. Das ist halt nicht einfach nur, wir sind die coolen Kicker aus Berlin, wir können richtig gut Fußball spielen. Eigentlich könnte ich auch zum BVB oder sowas wechseln. Sondern mir fehlt da so ein bisschen die Ernsthaftigkeit. Also dieses, was ich dem Trainer zum Beispiel nicht absprechen kann, der immer sehr verbissen wirkt und vielleicht auch da ein bisschen zu verbissen teilweise ist. Und das war eine absolute Trotzreaktion von ihm nach dem Spiel in Pärdervorne. Also es war wirklich wie so eine beleidigte Leberwurst, aber gleichzeitig auch sehr klar und eine realistische Einschätzung der Situation gegeben. Maßlos enttäuschter Trainer. Hab mich auch gewundert, dass er noch da ist. Aber wahrscheinlich auch, weil sie im Verein gesagt haben, okay, jetzt klappt es eh nicht mehr, dann machen wir das mit ihm noch diese Saison zu Ende oder so. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der darüber hinaus bleiben wird. Boah, das ist eine ganz komische Situation in Berlin. Das ist die ganzen letzten Jahre mit Pall Dada und diese ganzen, also die Entwicklung ist nicht positiv. Du hast nicht so dieses, was du auch in Gelsenkirchen hattest, so dieses, boah, sie lernen nicht aus den Fehlern, was du in Hamburg lange Zeit hattest. Sie lernen nicht aus den Fehlern. Sie machen immer wieder den gleichen Quatsch und landen immer wieder auf der Nase. Und das hast du in Berlin auch. Das ist einfach der Punkt, offenbar noch nicht erreicht, wo sie sich sagen, so, und jetzt machen wir mal was ganz anders. Wir versuchen jetzt mal wirklich was Neues. Marc hatte ja diesen Berliner Weg auch hier in einer Sendung mal ganz nett skizziert. Man hatte ja vor, auch mit jungen Spielern zu arbeiten, und so weiter, Berliner Talente zu fördern. Ja, was bleibt aber nachher übrig? Ich bin halt einfach in der 2. Liga kein Freund, auch wenn er den Geko grad netzt wie sonst was davon, dass man halt ein, zwei Stars im Team hat. Das geht oft in die Hose, meiner Ansicht nach. Sowas, was wir die letzten Jahre gezeigt haben, auch welche Mannschaften letztendlich dann aufgestiegen sind. Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, also ich glaube, es kann natürlich schon funktionieren, aber es ist natürlich immer eine Frage. Natürlich. Ich habe bei JK auch die Frage gestellt, Zerstören, die Wintertransfer, so ein bisschen diese Geschlossenheit aus der Schalke agiert hat, sah kurz so aus. Sie haben sich wieder gefangen. Ich hatte, also das eben, was ich beispielsweise von Fabian Reese eben gestern gesehen hatte, ich finde, dem hast du bei jeder Aktion Frust angemerkt. Und der Mann ist halt Kapitän dieser Mannschaft. Also der, wo ich immer wieder auch zwischendurch gesagt habe, in seiner Best-Form ist Fabian Reese das Beste, was Hertha passieren kann. Wenn aber etwas, wo ich glaube nicht läuft, wie er sich das vorgestellt hat, und das wird dieser nicht gelungene Aufstieg gewesen sein, glaube ich schon, dass der auch gut zu kämpfen hat. Und das ist auch komplett menschlich, das will ich ihm überhaupt nicht absprechen. Aber dass du es so offensiv auf dem Platz siehst, sollte dir halt nicht passieren. Und ich habe da auch kurz mit Marc darüber gesprochen, der hat mir das auch bestätigt. Also das ist jetzt keine Außenwahl. Ich meine, ich habe immer auch wieder meine Kritik an Fabi Reese geäußert. Und ja, das kann halt in zwei Richtungen funktionieren. Aber wenn du halt siehst, dass das anstatt dass jemand wie Reese als Kapitän dann auch vorweggeht, aber du hast gerade bei ihm das Gefühl, das geht jetzt auch auf so ein Ego-Ding hinten raus. So, aber Hauptsache ich mache irgendwie noch mein Ding. Das ist ein Angriff, das ist mir bewusst, den ich jetzt auch an ihn äußere. Und man muss ja auch sagen, es hätte ja auch alles funktionieren können.
Hat ja die Sorge davor auch schon nicht funktioniert.
Naja, klar. Also, wie gesagt, Stefan Leitel… Den Padawan hast du ihn auch nicht gesehen. Bleibt da für mich auch weiterhin… Du hast eben seine Kommunikation ein bisschen angesprochen. Ich habe zwischendurch immer schon mal wieder gesagt, dass ich… Mir ist es vollkommen egal, wie der sich seinen… Mir ist es nicht vollkommen egal, wenn er schlimme Sachen macht. Es ist mir nicht egal. Aber im Sinne von, was er intern an sein Team weitergibt nach Punktverlusten etc. ist mir relativ egal. Persi erstmal. Aber du musst dich halt nach außen hin schon irgendwie präsentieren und eben dann nicht direkt wirken, wie halt so ein angefressenes Kind, was du dem das Eis gerade weggenommen hast. Und das war mir dann manchmal, es ist vollkommen okay, dass du enttäuscht bist. Aber als Trainer solltest du in dieser Situation da vielleicht nicht irgendwie direkt so eine Trotzreaktion. Und das hatte, glaube ich, auch rund um dieses Nürnbergs Spieler, der auch nochmal gesagt hat, ja, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, warum wir immer nicht direkt sein sollen. Ja, also ich meine, es ist ja auch vollkommen okay, dass man es klar benennt, dass der Ausstieg weg, also rein rechnerisch noch möglich ist. Rein fußballphilosophisch, sage ich jetzt mal, war es halt weg.
Du kannst ja angefressen sein. Will ich ja auch, dass die Menschen ihre Emotionen zeigen. Und sie sollen auch direkt sagen, was sich stört. Bin ich ein großer Freund von. Aber das ist halt einfach ein Unterschied, ob du da unprofessionell sitzt und einfach flapsig bist, so wie damals Klaus Augenthaler irgendwie, oder keine Ahnung. Es gab ja schon viele Beispiele von Trainern, die Steffen Baumgart und Co., die aber trotzdem ein Niveau gehalten haben, wo du dann Gesicht warst. Wo du auch dann nicht den einen… Also ich meine, du setzt dich hin und sagst, die Saison ist gelaufen. Das sind noch zehn Spiele zu gehen, als er das gesagt hat. Wie willst du denn, dass ein Faner kleiner eine Dauerkarte gekauft hat? Oder ich weiß nicht. Klar, die sind ja auch nicht doof, die Fans. Aber du willst ja trotzdem dann erwarten, dass die Mannschaft dann auch Folge hast. Gibt und wenn du dann die Ego-Show, die du gerade beschrieben hast, die sicherlich nicht nur der Kollege Reese dann am Tag legt, aber bei ihm fällt es halt auf, weil er eben der Fokusspieler ist, im Spotlight steht. Dann ist das, das geht nicht. Das finde ich einfach, das ist unprofessionell. Das hat nichts mit 1. und 2. Liga zu tun. Es ist menschlich ja, dass man enttäuscht ist, dass man vielleicht auch bockig und beleidigt ist oder denkt, die ganzen Mitspieler sind alle unfähig. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber das geht von der Kreisliga bis zur Bundesliga. Wenn du dann nicht der Teamplayer bist, dann hast du nicht der Kapitän zu sein und dann brauchst du auch keine Ansprüche anstellen, um mitzuspielen. Diese Spieler werden einfach nie ganz oben stehen. Das ist einfach so. Da kann er noch so talentiert sein. Bisher hat das nicht bewiesen, dass er eine Mannschaft zumindest dahin führen kann. Das ist so meine Sicht von außen, kann völlig falsch sein. Ich mag ihm persönlich auch gar nichts Böses. Ich kenne ihn ja gar nicht. Kann ganz lieber Junge sein, aber das ist das Bild, was die Hertha so nach außen hin gibt. Das ist nicht zum ersten Mal so in den letzten Jahren. Völlig überhöhte Ambitionen, Ansprüche. Schon bin ich sofort fertig, vom Investor her angefangen. Mich regt das immer auf, diese ganzen Nummern. Das sind so Ansprüche, wo ich mich immer frage, wo kommen die her? Du hast lange erste Liga gespielt, aber du musst, dass es keinen Lerneffekt gibt. Das finde ich immer total krass. In einer freien Wirtschaft würden diese ganzen Menschen einfach gar nicht in diese Position kommen. So, Entschuldigung.
Thomas, was ist dein Statement dazu?
Also ich bin grundsätzlich eigentlich immer ein Freund davon. Nicht nur grundsätzlich, ich bin ein großer Freund davon, wenn Vereine auch Ziele klar formulieren. Also ich kann mit diesem ganzen, auch bei uns hier, was ihr seit Jahren... Ja, wir wollen eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen. Also was soll das? Also sag doch einfach, du willst mehr Punkte holen als im letzten Jahr, dann ist doch das eine schöne Aussage. Das ist doch ein Ziel, an dem man sich messen kann. Und Hertha hat halt das ganz große Ziel ausgerufen. Finde ich persönlich jetzt erstmal gar nichts Verwerfliches daran, zu sagen, wir wollen aufsteigen. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich finde es cool, wenn Mannschaften oder Vereine eben auch ganz klar sich Ziele setzen und diese auch nach außen formulieren. Das ist mir lieber als dieses Phrasen-Gedresche von irgendwelchen Sportdirektoren, die dann sagen, wir wollen den nächsten Schritt machen und dieses ganze Quatsche. Da kann ja auch überhaupt nichts mit anfangen. Von daher finde ich das, was Hertha da gemacht hat, grundsätzlich erstmal schön. Natürlich machst du dich dann auch angreifbar, wenn es nicht funktioniert, das ist ganz klar. Du bist dann natürlich der Depp vom Dienst, wenn du dich dann hinschält, sagst, wir wollen aufsteigen und nach 24 Spieltagen dich hinschält, sagst du, das war es jetzt mit der Saison. Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ich kann auch sehr naiv sein, aber vielleicht ist es auch tatsächlich von Leitel so, so eine letzte Patrone gewesen zu sagen, ich kitzel die Mannschaft jetzt richtig nach dem Spiel in Paderborn und sage hier so, da war es, Song ist vorbei, um vielleicht auch eine Reaktion zu erzeugen. Und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie die nächsten Wochen in Berlin laufen. Diese Liga zeigt ja eins auf beeindruckende Art und Weise. Du musst nicht schön Fußball spielen. Du musst erfolgreich Fußball spielen. Das zeigt Schalke auf sehr beeindruckende Art und Weise. Und wir spielen einen vermeintlich tollen Fußball. Guck, wo noch Tabelle stehen. Da kannst du dir nichts verkaufen. Du musst einfach spielen. Und wenn Hertha das jetzt vielleicht schafft und vielleicht war das genau, ich kann auch sehr naiv von mir sein jetzt. Einfach nur so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, weil ich eben auch der Meinung bin, Hertha ist halt auch, weiß ich nicht, also ich bin kein Fan von Hertha BST Berlin, aber ich muss sagen, ich hätte jetzt kein Problem, wenn wir in die 1. Bundesliga spielen würden. Und von daher kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es vielleicht einfach so ein psychologischer Kniff nochmal war, da nochmal so wirklich seine letzte Patrone rauszahnt. Ich kitzel die jetzt wirklich bei der Ehre. Vielleicht klappt es, vielleicht doch nicht, vielleicht sehe ich das auch völlig falsch und Leitel weiß wirklich nicht mehr weiter. Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass Kevin auch vollkommen recht ist. Vielleicht ist er einfach mit seinen Dateien auch am Ende, weiß nicht mehr weiter und weiß vielleicht auch schon, dass am Saisonende vielleicht sogar schon viel entschluss ist. Wer weiß, was da intern besprochen ist. Aber ich sehe es immer noch so, vielleicht war das einfach nur, jetzt mache ich die Mannschaft vielleicht nochmal auf eine andere Art und Weise wach.
Ich glaube bei Leitel ist eben, dass er natürlich jetzt mit Hannover lange im Spotlight stand und jetzt eben mit der Hertha und man ihm mehrere Male quasi so das, inwieweit man ihm es vielleicht auch vor die Nase gesetzt hat. Dieses Zielaufstieg, bei Hannover war es ein bisschen anders als bei der Hertha jetzt, ist natürlich auch so eine Sache. Aber deshalb gucken wir da glaube ich alle auch nochmal durch so eine andere Brille durch, glaube ich. Weil wir eben irgendwie so das Gefühl haben, ja er wird ja irgendwie immer wieder als dieser Aufstiegstrainer oder als der Perspektiv-Trainer geholt. Aber es reichte halt bisher nicht. Und was er mit Führt geschafft hat, ich meine frag mich, wie gerne er den Stefan Neidl von ein paar Jahren wieder bei Führt sehen würde. Klar. Aber ich glaube, das ist das, warum da viele auch kritisch drauf sehen. Und ich empfehle an der Stelle natürlich einfach, bei Hertha Bays einfach mal vorbeizuschauen. Die werden euch das alles noch ein bisschen tiefer erklären können, als wir das hier machen können. Und ich weiß auch, wenn ich hier sitze und ich Mark, dann schaue ich natürlich meistens ein bisschen anders auf die Hertha, auch weil Mark und ich von Anfang an eben diesen Streitpunkt vor der Saison hatten, was Hertha BSC und die Ausstiegsträume betrifft. Das ist mir auch bewusst. Aber ich weiß eben auch, dass Mark natürlich auch so ein bisschen kritisiert hat, dass zum Beispiel Vergleiche mit dem HSV komplett hinken. Weil alleine die finanzielle Voraussetzung, die beide Vereine haben oder eben auch die Not, die bei Hertha hinter setzt– ich sage es gerne nochmal– natürlich ein Problem sind. Du hast dieses ewige Thema Olympiastadion versus eigene Stadion, was du natürlich nicht realisieren kannst, wenn du Jahr für Jahr 2. Liga spielst. Das willst du dir natürlich schon mit einer gewissen finanziellen Stabilität, mit Perspektive auf Bundesliga-Fußball bauen. Ich glaube, da hängt einfach so viel hinter, dass es natürlich auch eine emotionale Sache ist. Du formulierst ja auch, sagst, wir wollen aufsteigen, um mögliche Spieler zu holen, die du sonst vielleicht nicht kriegen könntest, um Sponsoren und sonstige Geldgeber hinter dich zu bekommen, die du sonst vielleicht nicht hinter dich bekommen würdest, wenn du jede Saison sagst, wir gucken mal, wo das hinführt. Ich verstehe das auch alles, Thomas. Da bin ich auf deiner Seite, also per se bin ich auch mehr Fan davon, zu sagen, wir wollen aussteigen, aber du musst das, was du forderst, auch füttern. Und wenn du alleine auf die– das haben wir immer wieder gesprochen– die Transferpolitik von Hertha BSC, die hängt da einfach hinterher. Du hast zur Winterpause noch Josep Brekalo geholt, so, ne, also wieder so jemand, wo du dir irgendwie vielleicht was Gleiches wie bei Jede Niko Medjajka erhofft hast. Du hast eben die teuren Verträge von Reze und Croissants. Gleichzeitig hast du mit Luca Schuller und Gröning zwei Stürmer, die wirklich also bei allem Respekt ihren Job absolut gar nicht erfüllen, ne, also und das kommt eben auch noch alles dazu. Und das sowas kann laufen, ne. Du hattest natürlich auch Pech mit Verletzungen mit Jugendspielern, die eigentlich gerade reinkamen und eigentlich wo du dachtest, boah, die bringen einfach noch mal Euphorie mit. Und das ist alles nicht auf, die verletzen sich dann etc. Das ist auch alles super bitter. Und ich verstehe da auch jeden Hertha-Fan mit Frust, ne. Also dafür habe ich zu viele in meinem Umfeld. Und ich bin auch per se der Meinung, der Bundesliga wird da ein zweiter Hauptstadtclub gut tun. Aber, also sagen wir auch mal so, würden die jetzt so noch aufsteigen, wissen wir, ob es in der Bundesliga funktioniert so? Also das ist natürlich auch immer die Frage, ne. Du musst als anders, das ist genau wie mit Schalke, wir erwarten von Vereinen wie Schalke und Hertha, dann natürlich auch ein ganz anderes Auftreten in der Bundesliga, als wir von Darmstadt, Elbersberg oder Paderborn erwarten würden. Das ist überhaupt nicht dispektierlich gegenüber den anderen drei Vereinen gemeint, aber weil eben Hertha und Schalke mit einem ganz anderen Anspruchdenken in die Bundesliga aufsteigen würden oder aussteigen und da sich selber auch eine andere Historie mitbringen, erwarten wir natürlich von ihnen auch was anderes und erwarten natürlich alle im Umfeld auch was anderes, ne. Also alleine auch aus Vereinspolitischer Sicht, so. Das waren noch meine drei Sens dazu. Jetzt habe ich euch in die Stille verabschiedet.
Nö, ich habe so viel geredet, ich wusste nicht, ob ich nochmal was sagen darf.
Ihr dürft immer was sagen, hier gibt es kein Redeverbot.
Nein, das ist alles richtig, aber trotzdem, finde ich, muss so ein Verein halt auch immer mal seine Grundpfeiler überdenken. Und natürlich ist da eine finanzielle Not hinter und auch Druck aus dem Umfeld. Und das ist mir alles bewusst. Ich sage ja auch nicht, dass man dann alles abreißt und von Null wieder anfangen muss. Aber und ich finde auch gut, wenn Mannschaften ihre Ansprüche formulieren. Also wir machen das ja so, wir wollen ja jedes Jahr uns verbessern. Damit sind wir jetzt ganz gut gefahren in der Saison. Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber ich finde, Hertha ist noch nicht reif. Da bin ich bei dir. Und damit kann es aus meiner Sicht auch schließen. Das hast du, glaube ich, ganz gut gesagt. Die sind nicht reif dafür, aufzusteigen. 40 Punkte zu diesem Zeitpunkt mit dem Spielverläufen. Puh, nee.
Also ich meine, das Einzige ist, wenn man mal zur Hinrunde guckt, kommen jetzt natürlich so einige Spiele, wo man in der Hinrunde eben noch Punkte geholt haben. Also man spielt jetzt eigentlich nur noch gegen Teams aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte, außer Kaiserslautern. Also du spielst jetzt eben zu Hause gegen Bochum, also ja, okay, auswärts in Düsseldorf, klammer ich, Düsseldorf würde ich jetzt auch in der aktuellen Lage mal so ein bisschen ausklammern. Dann eben auswärts bei Dresden, zu Hause gegen Kaiserslautern, auswärts Braunschrank, zu Hause gegen Kiel, auswärts Magdeburg, zu Hause gegen Fürth, auswärts bei Minervillefeld. So, das ist dein Endspurt. Also, da kannst du natürlich hinten raus noch gute Laune und Aufbruchstimmung verbreiten. Das ist natürlich auch schon so. Aber da wird eben ein großer Aderlass kommen im Sommer. Und ich meine, der Vorteil ist vielleicht dahingehend, dass du jetzt eben planen kannst und du kannst jetzt eben frühzeitig– und das ist vielleicht ein Vorteil gegenüber anderen Vereinen, die eben am Ende auch in der Liga bleiben werden, obwohl sie dachten, da geht vielleicht mehr– dass du da vielleicht einfach den Vorteil hast, dass du schneller reagieren kannst. Du kannst jetzt schon gewisse Gespräche führen. Das könnte ein Vorteil sein. Aber gleichzeitig ist halt auch klar, dass du das Ziel aufstieg, kannst du in der nächsten Saison so meiner Meinung nach erstmal nicht nochmal verkünden, weil das allein finanziell nicht möglich sein wird. Aus meiner Perspektive heraus vorsichtig formuliert. Und das eben auch so ein bisschen das, was ich jetzt quer gelesen habe von allen möglichen Leuten, die eindeutig näher am Verein sind, als ich es bin. Gut, dann würde ich aber sagen, schnell kurz bevor wir die 2-Stunden-Marke hier noch knacken. Ich dachte kurz, wir wären sehr gut in der Zeit. Na ja, sind wir natürlich immer noch. Und es hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht mit euch beiden. Vielen Dank erstmal an Thomas, der mal wieder dabei war. Vielen Dank, dass du uns hier wieder deine Perspektive auf den FCM, aber generell auch auf die restliche Liga gegeben hast. Und natürlich bei euch auch gerne im Podcast reinhören.
War sehr schön. Danke für die Einladung.
Und dann natürlich auch liebe Grüße an Kevin. Gehen raus an der Stelle. Danke, dass du auch wieder dabei warst. Und auch immer sehr, ihr beide seid immer sehr schnell dabei, euch auch zu melden. Und das schätzen wir euch natürlich auch sehr. Aber ich sage schon mal so, am Samstag, da ruht dann die positiven Gedanken kurz Richtung Paderborn.
Bitte? Warum? Ach so, da ist ja was. Die Karten waren so schnell wie bei kaum anderem Spiel vergriffen. Also das Auswärtskontingent.
Ja, ist ja auch ein kurzer Weg.
Ja, aber es war ja trotzdem nicht immer so.
Ja, stimmt. Wir haben bestimmt auch was mit der aktuellen Lage zu tun. Von beiden Vereinen wahrscheinlich. Aber wie gesagt, vielen Dank, dass du auch dabei warst.
Danke für die Einladung.
Dann würde ich jetzt sagen, schön, dass ihr wieder zugehört habt. Feedback gerne einfach im Forum hinterlassen oder bei YouTube lese ich es meistens auch. Und dann würde ich sagen, wir vielleicht nicht, aber dieser Podcast ist in zwei Wochen wieder zurück. Sollte nichts anderes passieren. Ich klopfe auf Holz. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.